Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Dinos bin beunruhigt ich habe gehört du gehst jetzt mit anderen Tim senden.
Ja der andere Kind hat einen lustigen Hund und du nicht.
Aux
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 286 live und in Farbe vom 13. Februar 2019 habe ich richtige ja gesagt ja habe ich gesagt.
Aber wird es würde sich beschwert das irgendwie die MP3s noch 2018 getagged sind oder so.
Es war richtig ist aber behoben.
Okay dann bin ich ja dann bin ich beruhigt.
Ich habe dafür extra eine Zeitreise übernommen.
Ja aber ich war auch überrascht dass wir 2019 noch MP3s verteilen schädlich für den den größeren Witz.
Das ist doch jetzt frei.
Jetzt darf man das erst ne wo wir benutzen aber primär primär korrekt ist glaube ich AAC oder in dem.
Es gibt in dem Sinne keinen primären Codec Fürbitten noch alles an aber mittlerweile hat sich in der Podcast Landschaft,
eigentlich mp3 final durch Gesetz spätestens jetzt dadurch dass es komplett frei geworden ist und dadurch dass auch die
neueren Standard wie Kapitelmarken da jetzt auch bei Apple endlich Akzeptanz gefunden haben.
Also Standard durchgesetzt falls bei dir Apple hat auch noch weil das stimmt eigentlich nicht also wenn Apple das dann auch noch mitmacht.
Dann hat er sich durchgesetzt naja.
Dann hat es sich wirklich auch gegen Widerstand durchgesetzt.
Na gut ich meine das Apple deine Dominanz hat und eine große Bedeutung das ist ja vollkommen außer Frage.
Wir wollten ja eben bisschen über Podcasting reden jetzt oder.
Sag mir was Podcasting reden.
Auto muss gleich erstmal noch mal erzählen was wo du fremdgegangen bist.
Beim Kinderkanal.
Mit ich glaube der Moderator heißt Tim Gailus.
Timster heißt das dann ne.
Die Sendung heißt timster,
und der der es ist eine so eine Wissenssendung im Kinderkanal fand ich weil ich mal sehr interessant also man sieht vielleicht ist seine etwas ungewohnt her fahren meine Kinder sind jetzt nicht mein übliches wenn übrigens anspreche,
meine ansprech Zielgruppe ist es sein weil ich da ein bisschen hilflos wie man es Sachen.
Hat was ich ganz gut gemacht.
Aber man sieht glaubt also man sieht dass ich da vielleicht etwas nervöser oder unsichere auftrete als letzte Wäsche was weiß ich in Tagesthemen da da weiß man ja wenigstens dass man klüger ist als das Publikum,
beim Kinderkanal ist das nicht so einfach her.
Bestimmt.
Ja ich war also ich muss mal sagen ich war ja ich habe jetzt keine ich habe keinen Fernseher ich gucke kein Fernsehen ich gucke kein Kinderkanal ich war aber äußerst,
positiv überrascht mal zu sehen wie viele Leute da wie viel Zeit und Energie in
jetzt so eine sende Viertelstunde setzen also Feier ein Tag aufzeichnung mit dem großen Team.
Längere Vorbereitung des distributes der Inhalte und so weiter und.
Ja die waren jetzt wirklich interessiert irgendwie diese Sachen rüberzubringen und immer zu überlegen okay wir können wir dieses Thema jetzt rüberbringen dass das irgendwie Kinder verstehen und wie macht man das einfacher was ist da die Analogie und.
Ich habe jetzt also keine Ahnung kann jetzt früher Vivi,
Sendung mit der Maus geguckt und so Wissenssendungen natürlich ne das ist wirklich sehr sehr schön zu sehen wie viel wie viel Mühe sich da gegeben wird im Vergleich zu wenn jetzt mal irgendwie Wissenssendungen für,
Erwachsene schaust ja in privat TV ja also wenn die irgendwie so,
ProSieben Galileo oder so kokse woher das alles irgendwie halt ist so möglichst irgendwie
aufregende klicken Sie nicht weg oder so und halt mal so öffentlich-rechtlich für Kinder von Leuten die da echt Ahnung von haben die in dem Bereich studiert sind und so das ist schon hat er hatte fand ich sehr,
sehr gut zu sehen sehr beruhigend.
Gerade das Programm bei kika gratis die Wissenssendung sind
hervorragend also ich meine angeführt natürlich durch die Superstar Sendung Wissen macht Ah aber auch viele andere Sachen da diese Checker Sachen dass ich schau das selber immer wieder,
großer Begeisterung mit Zoo,
und find's gut wie aktuell das ist teilweise also dass sie da auch überhaupt gar keinen.
Gar keine Angst haben sich auch annanan komplizierte Sachen heran zutrauen und es ist es ist halt auch wirklich nicht so auf Verdummung gemacht so nach dem Motto,
hier ihr seid ja nur Kinder an jetzt weiß er jetzt jetzt jetzt ist brechen wir das mal so weit runter bis da überhaupt gar keinen Funken Wahrheit mehr drin ist ne ganz im Gegenteil dass es ist alles immer sehr schön zusammengesetzt und.
Also insofern finde ich das fast noch erstrebenswerter für dich mal da aufgetreten zu sein als jetzt bei den üblichen Erwachsenen Paukern.
Ja ich war also ich fand es auf jeden Fall aufregen mache ich gerne mal wieder warenwandel Duschwanne interessante Erfahrungen also auch irgendwie denn sie haben ja ja diesen Hund ne diesen Louis
der durfte bei uns jetzt nicht soviel mitspielen musste aber natürlich da sein und nicht hier sein Fernsehen und ne,
der kann relativ viel was man dir sagt so irgendwie setze ich ihn halt die Schnauze kann der Jana und,
können die meisten Hunde nicht ne und das aber auch geh mal darüber hol mal hier was Abtrag dass man dahin und so ne nicht unterwegs essen und das war schon,
ja es ist schön zu sehen was da so alles was wir so alle.
Nein lieber ist also hast du keinen Hund aber du hast ja mich.
Du bist zwar nicht ganz so geilos aber.
Verbinde mit wenn du mir sagst ich soll die Schnauze halten dann kann ich das auch meistens.
Muss ich dir hätte ich sage Kurzmeldung.
Nee das geht gar nicht das triggert mich total.
16 Triggerbot für dich also Kinderfernsehen habe ich mir jetzt auch mal angeguckt und für gut befunden hat nicht ein bisschen.
Ich hadere ja mit mit dem Medienumfeld,
was du was ich so wo du hier täglich durchschlagen muss mit der Machete um irgendwie mal zum zum,
Kern des Pudels zu kommen und da war ich sehr sehr erfreut dass es da für Kinder bei ordentliche Angebote du die anderen es auch nachher nach der Sendung war noch so ein Chat.
Er muss immer also dann war noch eine Stunde Chat und dann gibt's halt quasi den Kika chat da konnten die Kinder noch ihre Fragen stellen und das ist dann auch der Moderator drin und irgendwelche,
Leute die heute im Umgang mit Kindern geschult sind und so und dann durfte man dann da halt irgendwie dann und wie gesagt ja hier ich habe manchmal iPhone gewonnen und nein hast du nicht die wollen dich verarschen und das hat das schon wirklich ein schönes Angebot.
Wie viel Zeit war zwischen Aufnahme und Ausstrahlung und diesem Chip.
Nicht viel das fand ich auch noch überraschend dass die aufteilen weil gleich am Mittwoch die Sendung war am Samstag.
War sportlich.
Aber wenn ich mich jetzt nicht täusche haben war der.
Der Entschluss dass wir das machen so ungefähr zwei Wochen vorher und die hatten halt auch einen ein Drehbuch ne also im Sinne von,
jetzt nicht irgendwie gescriptet was man sagt aber schon so jetzt und er hat jetzt sitzt ihr da und unterhaltet euch über folgendes Thema vorher kam dieser Einspieler da war ja auch der ein kurzer ein Spieler oder gar nicht so kurze allschwill längere Einspieler,
mit dem Fabian Siegismund den wir ja hier auch als Betroffenen dieses Promiboxen erwähnt hatten,
und der war der auch das siehst du die haben sich da,
wirklich also der hat ordentlich recherchiert und Licht auf gearbeitet dann kann man nicht anders sagen somit mit einer betroffenen Personen und kinderreporterin die dann da irgendwie sich mit ihm unterhält und und natürlich dann irgendwie.
Inhalte so ein bisschen wiederholt ne erstmal kurz erwähnt dann noch mal im Detail erklärt und so das da sieht man schon da haben sich Leute da war der ist Zeit reingegangen.
Ja ich brauch das Gefühl nicht los geworden dass das sowieso ein Zusammenfassung der letzten 3 Sendung bei uns war so bisschen gespielten Spiel davor.
Letzte Mal gesehen hätte alles in der Stunde gepasst für wir müssen hier.
So um das auch dieses Mal in der Viertelstunde zu tanken, weil jetzt wird zu Feedback.
Na gut.
Sandra Admin kommentiert zudem posteo Thema meiner Ansicht nach habt ihr da,
ein bisschen was falsch verstanden
es ging nie darum das passt hier alle IP-Adressen protokollieren müsse sondern es ging darum dass sie sich auf den Standpunkt bestellt haben sie
könnten gar keine IP-Adressen protokollieren weil sie die nicht einem Postfach zuordnen können,
und das magst du im bezug auf das derzeitige System korrekt sein ist aber als Argument etwa so sinnvoll wie wir haben aber keinen Speicherplatz und die Adresse zu speichern.
Warum ist das ein und warum ist das ein Unterschied im Zweifelsfall der oder warum sagen Sie sie können es sich zu einem 24 Zoll weiß ich vorne irgendwie so ein.
So ein SSL Gateway Loadbalancer haben und hinten irgendwo so ein Mailserver und das jetzt quasi sein die IP-Adressen fange fallen an dem einen Gerät,
an und sept hatte Dich abholen der E-Mail passiert ja aber auf dem anderen Gerät und diese beiden Daten in Verbindung zu bringen
machen wir einfach nicht und es ist nicht ohne weiteres möglich und wir halten es auch nicht zumutbar dass wir das jetzt extra schaffen und jetzt sagt das Bundesverfassungsgericht doch wenn ihr gefragt habt dann,
solltet ihr das tun.
Und dann kommt die deshalb kommt Sandra zu dem Schluss deshalb finde ich das Urteil im Bezug auf seine Konsequenzen nicht so fragwürdig,
jetzt muss ja zu sein so hatte ich das auch verstanden ärgerlich wenn wir es dann nicht so erklärt haben insofern vielen Dank für die gute,
Klarstellung noch einmal von Sandra an dieser.
Noch weitere Zweifel an unseren Aussagen gab es dann zu der Netzneutralität Studie.
Genau da war die Aussage also die Aussage der Studie von epicenter works also dem Team um Thomas Lohninger war,
das nach der in den Ländern wo sie war Rating eingeführt wurde in der Folge darauf die Preise um 8%,
gestiegen sind im Schnitt und dann wurde von Martin bemängelt na ja hier.
Das ist das ist ja nur eine Korrelation
und überall wo jemand Korrelation hat er dass die sofort Korrelation ist kein keine kausation dem habe ich erst mal widersprochen weil ich sagen wenn du halt also erstens hat sie keine Karte keine Korrelation gerechnet sondern eine
multivariate Regression falls wir waren sofort in meinem Fach.
Kannst du das noch mal.
Jahre an der Uni unterrichtet aber die.
Multivariate Regressionsanalyse.
Aber ich will das jetzt gar nicht ins Detail minzhi verschließen
beides ging sofort in eine in eine methodische Diskussion und Martin hatte,
die Studie und den Annex auf jeden Fall dann noch mal genau gelesen und deswegen war ich sehr froh dass
Thomas sich meldete Thomas Lohninger und sagte.
Armistead ist das Englisch wir gucken, wie ich würde gerne den deutschen Teil nur zusammenfassen der relativ klar sagte ok.
Also dass er dass er quasi das irgendwie doof ich habe ich hatte die Idee den Text im Kopf nicht als Englisch gespeichert.
Na gut können wir ja vielleicht mal unsere Flyer setzen so also in zitiert aus seinem eigenen Report Seite 31 in in der Konklusion da wo wir statistisch signifikante Resultate
gefunden haben haben sie die initiale Hypothese bestätigt die Existenz oder Einführung von zero-rating angeboten
ist verbunden mit Märkten die einen Preisanstieg.
Haben.
Jetzt ist natürlich die Frage du kannst das natürlich sehr es ist relativ schwierig diesen Preisanstieg,
Zubehör
zu berechnen wenn die jetzt EW du musst ja genau überlegen was ist jetzt der Preisanstieg ne weil die du musst ja quasi als wenn du einen Preis haben willst musst ja quasi sagen dieser Preis hat irgendwie eine Bezugsgröße also was ist der Preis pro Gigabyte oder ne Sache einfach nur okay was ist der Preis der pro Monat gezahlt wurde wenn aber die Leistung natürlich sehr viel größer ist insofern kann man sich da
methodisch sehr viel drüber streiten die Frage von Martin varbelow City jetzt wegen des 7 ratings teurer geworden.
Oder ist es vielleicht umgekehrt dass da wo die Preise teurer geworden sind man noch so eine zero-rating mit dazu gegeben hat.
Um die höheren Preise ihre zu kaschieren und.
Die Analyse von epicenter works kommt quasi zu dem Ergebnis dass es zumindest nicht vorteilhaft ist,
haben dass dieses zero-rating eingeführt wird wurde und die methodischen Diskussionen über Regressionsanalysen Korrelation und Kausalität ich jetzt gar nicht so unbedingt,
vertiefen wollen ich habe nämlich da mich nur relativ methodischen zudem. Guinea,
wenn du alle Einflussfaktoren kontrolliert hast dann kannst du natürlich bei einer,
längsschnittlich in Regressionsanalyse auch auf eine Kaution Schließen der Streit ist natürlich dann wissenschaftlich hast du alle relevanten Faktoren erfasst sodass deine Regression alles abdeckt und alle
Kontrollvariablen erfasst.
Ist richtig verstanden habe soll auch so dass in den selber jetzt auch klar ist dass man jetzt die Untersuchung wie man sie bisher gemacht hat die halt die einzelnen Länder miteinander vergleichen sofern sich nicht mehr fortführen lässt weil in zunehmendem Maße die ganzen zero-rating Angebote jetzt überall
auftauchen und damit quasi Vergleich Masse schwindet
so oder so weißt aber darauf hin dass die österreichische Regierungsbehörde diese Studie mit Interesse aufgenommen hat und jetzt selber angekündigt hat mit sehr viel besseren Daten
und mit ausgefeilten statistischen Methoden das in der Zukunft fortzusetzen also insofern kann sich ja auf eine Kick-Off Leistungen,
geleistet vielleicht auch mal eine Gelegenheit mal mit Thomas noch mal genauer zu diesen Ergebnissen zu sprechen in einer zukünftigen Sendung.
Auf jeden Fall ist jede Menge,
Hirnschmalz in diese ganze Sache rein geflossen und sieht eben so aus als ob es mindestens auf nationaler wenn ich vielleicht irgendwann sogar auf EU-Ebene Direktion,
du befördert hat das eben jetzt die Regulierungsbehörden das aber genauer drauf schauen wie sich denn diese neuen Regeln auswirken.
Und ein sehr wichtiger Kommentar von Matthias zur Frage wie man Lion davon überzeugt.
Das sogenannte E-Voting keine gute Idee ist nennt es doch einfach Cybermobbing und dem schließe ich mich sofort an.
Cybermobbing ist der Begriff der einfach sehr viel schöner darstellt was hier so ein bisschen das Problem ist und ich beobachte gleichzeitig weiterhin.
See in der Schweiz die Debatte.
Leider immer noch versucht wird in die falsche Richtung zu führen ja einer der Anbieter die,
versuchen dieses Zauberwort in der Schweiz über zu helfen indem sie es betreiben.
Ist die Schweizer Post die,
eine Webseite betreibt unter dem Namen unter der Domain E-Voting Block ja also ist ja auch wieder so ein bisschen her unabhängig Experte Pipapo weißt du nicht und sagt jetzt wir wir machen einen,
resilience testing auch bekannt als ein Public intrusion testing,
woanders würde man sagen Test vom 25.10 bis 24 März wo sie also Leute einladen ihr Cyber vaulting System.
Anzugreifen,
und wenn dieser Test vorbei ist das ist natürlich die Idee eines solchen Test ist ne dann wollen sie entweder die Schwachstellen,
Entfernung natürlich am Ende eines solchen Tests steht ja dann das Ergebnis das System ist jetzt auf jeden Fall sicherer oder es war schon sicher und ich finde das ist eine eine ganz ganz ungünstige Ablenkung.
In die falsche Richtung es geht hier nicht darum dass dieses System,
sicher ist oder unsicher es geht um viel mehr es geht darum dass dieses System nicht,
kontrollierbar ist und das ist eine Gefahr für den Glauben an die Demokratie darstellt wenn man mit solchen Cybermobbing,
System dann auch noch hier aus so öffentlich privat komischer Unternehmens Hand kommt und insofern kann man eigentlich nur sagen.
Es wäre sein ich allen dazu geraten nicht dazu beizutragen sondern sich einfach öffentlich davon zu distanzieren zumal die in the night diddy.
Die bug-bounty sicher ausloben sind natürlich,
FIBA sind nicht so schlecht ja wer die geheime guide das Geld das Geheimnis der Wahl angreift 10000 Schweizer Franken.
Eine Manipulation die aber die diktiert wird 20000 Schweizer Franken eine Manipulation die nicht detektiert wird,
30 bis 50 sehr spannend dieser pentest ist ja zeitlich beschränkt ja das heißt die können im Zweifelsfall das System in der Zeit sehr genau Monitoren und ich finde so
kann also immer nur davor warnen an solchen pentest die im Rahmen einer PR-Kampagne stattfinden oder sogar noch zeitlich begrenzt sind sich zu beteiligen das sind eigentlich immer nur so Aufrufe in irgendeiner folgen
sich medial ausnutzen zu lassen ja.
Ja und wie du schon richtig gesagt hast ist es lenkt halt einfach total von dem von der eigentlichen Frage ab ne es geht hier überhaupt nicht darum also selbst wenn,
was weiß ich niemand über über 2 Jahre Dauertest und wo die Leute sogar nicht nur für Erfolg bezahlt werden sondern auch für das Testen ja du kannst ja rum auditieren wie du willst
das ist einfach vollkommen irrelevant wie sicher diese System angeblich ist schlicht weil du nicht weißt ob genau dieses System am Wahltag auch läuft,
oder nicht irgend eine ganz andere Software das ist das Kernproblem und deswegen sollte man sich da nicht von so bezahlbarer schicken da und Deitermann andere Begriff einzuführen verwirren lassen.
Also ein bisschen so wir führen eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung ein und sagen naja ihr könnt ja versuchen die zu hacken,
das ist nicht das Problem,
Problem ist nicht ob wir innerhalb eines Monats in der Lage sind 1 von euch Bescheid zeitlich eingegrenzt Zeitraums in der Lage sind das zu hacken sondern die Einführung das Problem ist die Einführung des Systems,
an sich deswegen keine Chance dem Cyberworld.
Ich bin aber ist dann auch über Umwege dann auch wieder auf Twitter also irgendwelche Diskussionen stop mit mit Amerikanern.
Ja und selbsternannten Computerexperten.
Oh ja die sind die besten.
Ja das ist auch wirklich absurd also da ist diese ganzen erzähle auch überhaupt nicht von freizusprechen weil einfach oft immer noch so ein glaube vorliegt,
das wird man das nur richtig macht in Anführungsstrichen dann geht das auch schon und das ist bisher nicht gemacht wurde na ja das läge ja nur da dran das nicht die super.
Noch keine blockchain war.
Dass er genau blockchain und keine Ahnung was dann.
Jana nur womit sich diese Leute überhaupt nicht beschäftigen das auf der einen Seite welche Prinzipien ist zu,
zu erhalten gilt bei so einer war ja da kommt dann auch so absurde Vergleiche wie naja aber wie kann es denn sein dass wir irgendwie täglich Milliarden von Dollar online überweisen aber man soll keine Abstimmung machen.
Sorry also wenn ihr wenn ihr das noch nicht verstanden habt dann müsst ihr euch mit dem Thema einfach noch mal ein bisschen tiefer auseinandersetzen weil das eine hat mit dem anderen einfach mal in jeder Hinsicht nichts zu tun.
Du Tim das aber für ein Amerikaner sehr schwer nachzuvollziehen dass Kapitalismus und Demokratie 2 Unterschied.
Das ist das darfst du den da musst du den schon sagen das wird den halt sehr früh ganz anders Balge.
Das war gerade aber das ist ja auch hier teilweise so verbreitet norms aber auch noch mal ein weiteres Mal klar gesagt zu haben
Gelder sind alle ins Haus fallen irgendwann auch nachvollziehbar da müssen um die Seiden Stimmen erzählte war dass das enthalten in gewisser Hinsicht öffentliche Information
die hast du halt bei einer Wahl nicht sonder geht's darum dass es alles Geheimnis und.
Verständlich sein das heißt egal was für ein beklopptes Crypto absicherungs überprüfungs Schlüssel Doppel Schlüsselsystem man sich da einfallen lässt das versteht am Ende einfach niemand mehr
und da da hätten wir dann wahrscheinlich auch Probleme Sonnensystem und wie in 3 stunden Logbuch Netzpolitik auch nur ansatzweise zu erklären dass wir selber verstehen und das kann nicht die Grundlage für eine Wahl sein
der am Ende alle vertrauen müssen,
dass das schon mit richtigen Dingen zugegangen ist ja der mich noch an so ein Chaos Radiosendung vor längerer Zeit schon mal zu dem Thema wo dann auch Leute anriefen.
Die Wahlhelfer waren und verschiedene Wahlhelfer waren halt zum Wahlbezirk wo eben,
ihr gewählt wurde und jeder wurde immer so gefragt und er hat das Gefühl dass er alles mit richtigen Dingen zuging und die so ja klar natürlich habe daneben gesessen das Gesetz war alles super und dann kam halt jemand der Inso Wahlcomputer Bezirk war
und kriegt halt die gleiche Frage und da war die Antwort gleich anders aus der also ich denke schon so ne.
Ja das sind sehr schönes.
Ich glaube ich glaube dass das schon gestimmt hat so nur glauben heißt nicht wissen und dann der Stelle ist das genau da,
Fulham.
Geheim nachvollziehbar und.
Fahr verleihen und das ist halt mit einfachen Mitteln mit Computern einfach nicht.
Durchführbar du opferst immer eins für Kosten der des anderen und deswegen des Kissens ist Cybermobbing einfach grundsätzlich nicht.
Sinnvoll
möglich und Seis am Ende von mir aus ja das Problem dass der größere Teil der Menschen nicht in der Lage ist ein ein geniales Cyber Voting blockchain Crypto
distributed 4.0 Modell zu verstehen dann scheitert es eben daran ja.
Mit Quantencomputer wird das alles.
Quanten Quanten Crypto Cyber blockchain wording 4.9 damit wird aber das ist inri.
Dann richtig richtig gut genau.
Innovation Innovation machen das machen wir alles egal.
Total.
Okay Arbeitsgeber Voting nein danke und Podcasting ja bitte du willst bestimmt noch was zählt zu den Satz gerade erzählen.
Na ja gut ich habe ja da schon ausführlich darüber berichtet werden uns jetzt gerade noch mal entschlossen paar mehr Tickets rauszugeben dies hat gerade wird damit etwas
größer als gedacht für wenn dann vermutlich so doppelt so viele Teilnehmer haben wie letztes mal wissen aber so übereingekommen dass wir das schon irgendwie hinbekommen ist ja eine Community Konferenz das heißt wir sitzen auch drauf
besser alle mithelfen das heißt die dicke Sven aber trotzdem,
gut nachgefragt sein also wer das jetzt hört wird sich eh nur noch eine Warteliste Warteliste eintragen können aber man merkte Podcasting.
Erfährt mehr Aufmerksamkeit teilweise mehr als einem lieb sein.
Ja ist doch das ist doch sehr schön Verein weil also ich habe da in letzter Zeit noch mal so ein bisschen Autobahn nachgedacht und mit ein paar Vertreterinnen und Vertretern drüber gequatscht.
Das.
Das ist schon irgendwie eine einzigartige Kultur in der das haben wir hat man in anderen Medien Formaten ist das einfach nicht geschafft worden ja also wenn es wenn es schon
nur Video ist.
Dann wenn du jetzt nur sagst ok es ist jetzt eben ein video podcast dann hast Du sofort dieses ganze YouTube Ding im Prinzip ne ein Unternehmen beherrscht den weltweiten Markt und nach dessen Konditionen und
der Vorgaben findet das jetzt statt Text hat sich in.
Nicht so sag mir mal die Idee dezentrale texte Blogs und so weiter vorzuhalten.
Ist auch nicht so gut gealtert ja sie funktioniert irgendwie noch aber ist eben auch da sehr,
mit hohen Einstiegshürden verbunden,
nicht unbedingt mit so viel freies verfährt Waka WordPress doch okay ich lasse mal WordPress noch so gelten Blogs gibt es so aber das ist jetzt irgendwie nicht ein Wachstumsmarkt dass Leute blogs betreiben,
Podcasts sind es ja Podcast nehmen zu und die Community ist zumindest in Deutschland,
auf eine sehr schöne Weise selbstbestimmt die Finanzierungsmodelle sind sehr viel direkt ja.
Was jetzt bei YouTube und sonstigen auch nicht unbedingt der Fall ist es gibt wirklich mit der podlove Software beeindruckende Open-Source-Projekte,
auch wenn ich manchmal,
hinter Forbo hinter vorgehaltener Hand mich über das eine oder andere aufrege aber wenigstens rege ich mich dann nur darüber auf dass ich selbst nicht die Zeit habe das zu fixen und nicht dass ich irgendwie unter der Gnade von.
Von Google oder sonst wem stehe.
Was zeichnet den Podcast aus der Podcast hat ein feet und ist damit abonnierbar mit jeder App eurer freien Wahl,
im Gegensatz zu z.b. YouTube oder Spotify und Spotify hat sich jetzt überlegt wir wollen mit Podcast weiter wachsen,
dass ich nicht gut dass ich dich richtig weil Spotify hat keine Podcasts denn das sind ja er mir kein feat ich muss mich ja bei Spotify anmelden um diesen Mist zu hören und das ist schlecht.
Ja das auf jeden Fall ein Problem alle wollen natürlich jetzt das neue YouTube das
Castings werden jetzt vor allen so aufgefallen ist dass diese Podcast are nicht mehr weggehen und B auch noch eure gehört werden und vor allem
unglaubliche Zeitfresser sind das ist ja auch glaube ich das was gerade zu diesem ganzen hi zu unheimlich beschleunigt dass die Leute feststellen so
was wie Sendung irgendwie stundenlang mehrere die ganze Woche über die Leute haben die ganze Zeit die Stöpsel im Ohr,
Artefakt die in die nehmen unter die ganze erteilen für die anderen Medien weg.
Und ja genau meine habe ich ja schon immer gesagt dass,
den Orden kann ich mir wirklich vollkommen uneingeschränkt Umhängen mir das war das war von Anfang an mein Gefühl dass dass dass das genau diesen Effekt Leben,
hat und insofern ist es jetzt auch nicht weiter überraschend das natürlich alle versuchen da jetzt irgendwie möglich viel von dem Kuchen,
abzubekommen oder das als Basis für eine Expansion auch für andere Business Modelle zu machen sportify hat halt geschafft über diese Musik Stream viele Leute zum Hören zu bringen.
Ja oder zumindest dazu hören was was Sie im Angebot haben weil das eben bei Musik ganz gut funktioniert so diese Streaming Geschichte muss ich sagen aber ich haben Anfang auch noch so ein bisschen skeptisch aber mittlerweile
verstehe ich dass dass das eigentlich total sinnvoll ist da quasi in so einem Flatrate
Modell das alles anzubieten weil dieses einzelne kaufen von Musikstücken einfach nicht skalierte und bei Podcast allerdings
ist das die Hörgewohnheiten anders und wir versuchen da jetzt zwei Dinge zusammenzubringen.
Kann gut sein dass sie gelernt haben kann gut sein dass sie da mittlerweile weg haben nur,
in dem Moment wo sie halt an dieses offene Modell rangehen wollen sind Sie herzlich schon so ein bisschen der Feind
dann das geht nicht nur für Spotify es gab ja schon verschiedene andere Versuche stitcher etc.pp also alle wollten irgendwie so die Plattform sein wo eben erzeugt wird wo angeboten wird wo gehört wird
um die Leute daneben Intent als Falte in der eigenen App zu halten,
Spotify kauft jetzt fleißig ein sie kaufen sich sowohl Produzenten gimlet Media IV Podcast machen am sie sich irgendwie einverleibt dann irgendwie auch andere Plattformen,
creation Pack Plattformen wie ein Koi sich gemopst mir ist die Dimensionen dieses Unternehmens noch nicht so ganz klar die haben am Anfang auch mit so einem,
ja gab schon mal Audio Busen bisschen so Audio Twitter nicht sprich was rein und sofort ist das veröffentlicht das
hat natürlich nicht funktioniert weil
das Ganze kurz kurz kurz ist halt einfach nicht das Wesen von Podcast das hat einfach sehr viel mehr mit Regelmäßigkeit mit Ausführlichkeit zu tun ob das jetzt eine Gewinnerstraße ist auf die sich da begeben ich weiß es nicht hoffe natürlich nicht.
Weil ich denke dass das Ganze Podcast Wesen enorm davon profitiert hat das ist bis heute so frei und offen geblieben ist,
und das ist das eben auch schnell ändern würde wenn der wenn die Vorzeichen sich da die Technik Vorzeichen sich da ändern.
Also wir haben feet.
Ich hoffe mal also ich würde dass ich würde es tatsächlich noch noch dramatischer sehen.
Und zwar nicht unbedingt über Hörgewohnheiten oder sonstwas sondern darüber dass dass das große teure Geld in dieser.
Plattformen und Aufmerksamkeitsökonomie einfach nur noch nach Möglichkeiten sucht.
Irgendwie an deinen Kopf zu kommen er und wenn du dir plötzlichen Kopfhörer aufsetzt und dein Smartphone in die Tasche steckst oder dein Laptop zuklappen oder deine iPad Weg legst und nur noch über die Ohren,
erreicht werden kannst dann ist das eben dass das ist der neue Wachstumsmarkt ja genauso wie dir teilweise in wir sagen ok dann müssen halt Plakatwerbung uns noch mal irgendwie anschauen Vivaldi über optimieren,
im Sinne von David die Aufmerksamkeit der Leute nicht verlieren und darauf die Leute in irgendeiner Form erfassen zu können.
Und das wird da glaube ich da wird in naher Zukunft noch sehr viel mehr Geld drauf geworfen werden diese kleine schöne,
Podcast Welt anzugreifen umso mehr freue ich mich dass wir inzwischen auch in Deutschland eben,
viele Formate aus unterschiedlichen Hintergründen haben.
Die es schaffen sich irgendwie aufrechtzuerhalten auch wenn mir diese ewige dieses ewige monetarisierungs Geschrei irgendwie persönlich auf den Geist geht,
finde ich natürlich trotzdem erfreulich dass das nicht unbedingt so praevalent ist wie in Deutschland
ein in den USA wo
irgendwie da hat die ganze Zeit mit Werbung der ja insofern freue ich mich über diese subscribed Community die da das Partnerprojekt voranbringen und das wollte ich an dieser Stelle mal loswerden dass podlove Projekt die eben mit dieser freien Software
den größeren Teil dieser Podcast Community überhaupt ermöglichen so eine feine Sache.
Bin in Deutschland, dass.
Kann man den nicht oft genug für.
Ja ich habe da.
So jetzt haben wir bei lange.
Genau ich hoffe dass wir da auch V hab's gerade ein paar schöne Neuigkeiten für euch haben.
Die USA live übertragen wird dass wir kein Ticket findet kann den Vorträgen auf jeden Fall auch lauschen und Nachgang der ohnehin.
Gut komme zu den schlechteren Nachrichten.
Genau hätte ich.
Artikel 13
ja das ist ja mittlerweile schon so zusammen Schlagwort geworden worüber reden wir natürlich über die Urheberrechtsreform die in der EU
mittlerweile auf dem finalen Weg es wären schon mehrfach darüber berichtet derzeit befindet sich das Ganze
in den finalen Verhandlungen den sogenannten trilogverhandlung also da wo Kommission Rat der Europäischen Union und das Parlament versuchen den abschließenden Deal zu machen nachdem die Kommission das Magen gestoßen hat,
und das Parlament dann deins Tempel unter zugegeben hat und hier hat mir leider das Problem dass Deutschland
und konkret eben Axel Voss von der CDU hier
Berichterstatter war und dafür gesorgt hat dass das Parlament schon einen sehr undankbaren Entwurf abgeliefert hat im Trilog hat sich das jetzt alles noch ein wenig verschärft zwischendurch und wir hatten auch darüber berichtet
gabs dann die Meldung dass ich aber dann verschiedene Länder dagegen gestellt haben und es tauchte so langsam so ein bisschen die Hoffnung auf dass,
ja die aufwachen den copyright holder in Europa dann auch gemerkt haben dass sie sich hier eigentlich letzten Endes nur den großen Plattform ausliefern
das mag im Detail auch so gewesen sein am Ende waren es dann aber nur elf Länder die dagegen waren das war in dem Sinne noch keine wirkliche Mehrheit die hätte etwas verhindern können trotzdem hat man sich hier versuchte am Konsens anzunähern.
Und am Ende zeigte sich dass es wohl im Wesentlichen die Fehde zwischen Frankreich und Deutschland war die haben sich jetzt auch auf eine Regelung geändert und surprise surprise es handelt sich dabei nicht um eine Regelung
der Artikel 13 keine Rolle mehr spielen würde ganz im Gegenteil man hat im Rahmen dieses Konsenses
offenbar die Sache einfach noch ein wenig verschärft und jetzt sind komischerweise auf einmal alle glücklich zumindest macht es gerade so den Eindruck als ob dem so sei
was waren diese Positionen,
im Wesentlichen war so dass Frankreich einfach gesagt hat nur hier konnten für uploadfilter das wollen aber einfach mal für alle und fertig aus also
frankreich muss man dazu sagen hat in der Hinsicht auch eine ganz andere Vergangenheit und baller schon immer sehr viel restriktiver unterwegs Deutschland war jetzt nicht unbedingt.
Kathi hat mir auch die Französische Revolution die wissen ja wohin das führt ist ja klar dass sie sagt.
Wir nicht normal.
Ja vor allem haben die aber auch noch mehr Kultur irgendwie also das hilft ja auch noch mal ganz gut ne Filmindustrie ecetera später noch mal eine größere Rolle als in Deutschland.
Soda so Deutschland Position war na ja im Prinzip wollen wir das ja auch hat ja der Axel Voss schon gesagt aber wir wollen ja die Startup schützen aber offensichtlich haben sie da zum ist kalte Füße bekommen oder hier das C-Netz oder so hat
die ganze Zeit mit deinen Drogen zu müssen bisschen Wind erzeugt wo dann sich alle
genötigt sein von der Regierungen her eine leicht andere Position einzunehmen ja also es geht ja jetzt hier um die Verhandlung im Rad
na also um die Position des Rat der Europäischen Union und nun das noch mal klar gesagt zu haben wir das nicht auf den Zeiger hat der Rat der Europäischen Union,
ist quasi die Versammlung aller Regierungen der Länder und es wird immer ein bisschen unterschätzt.
Der Mitgliedstaaten nicht Länder.
Mein Herz war nicht damit der Antike als der Mitgliedstaaten der Europäischen Union also jetzt halt 28 oder 27 nachdem wie man jetzt aktuell zählen möchte,
und deren Einfluss ist halt enorm und der drückt sich daneben primär auch immer in den trilogverhandlung aus weil letzten Endes das Parlament antwortet auf die Kommission legt ein Vorschlag vor und dann kann er halt vom rad noch ordentlich kaputt gemacht.
Wie wird das in der Regel dann auch oft ja und wie sieht dieser Kompromiss jetzt so aus,
also Deutschland hatte gesagt ok Startups müssen schützen bitte eine Ausnahme für Unternehmen die weniger als 20 Milliarden 20 Millionen Umsatz machen.
Und,
geeinigt hat man sich aber jetzt wohl offenbar zwischen Frankreich und Deutschland da also innerhalb des Rats zwischen Frankreich und Deutschland uploadfilter sollten trotzdem von allen installiert werden sollen es sei denn man,
erfüllt alle folgende drei Kriterien nämlich,
erstens diese Plattformen ist noch nicht länger als drei Jahre am Start,
das schließt auch schon mal alles von Heise Forum und so weiter aus also alles was irgendwie schon immer da ist in gewisser Hinsicht hat gar keine Chance.
Halbe Forum ist aber auch eine Keimzelle des Terror.
Aber die Copyrightverletzung und so also enorm mindestens einer hat schon mal Satz dort gepostet und ich vorher gesagt habe,
so aber halt auch alle anderen existierenden Plattform ne also 3 Jahre ist wirklich nicht viel Zeit und man muss halt eine Umsatz kleiner 10000000 Euro haben im Jahr.
Das dürfte dann auch nicht mehr so viel übrig bleiben.
Und außerdem muss man weniger als 5 Millionen unique monthly visitors haben also sozusagen 5 Millionen,
Besucher als auch eine interessante Definition stopp die webexperten Vergangenes gleich wieder an da zu unterscheiden mit was ist ein Visitor und was ist ein ein Unique User und so weiter
ist auch interessant wenn das sozusagen dokumentiert werden muss also wer misst denn dann das bitte genau ja ob das so viele sind
ja was da die Standards dafür spricht mit anderen Worten,
laut dem Rad und diesen Kompromiss zwischen Frankreich und Deutschland soll diese Regelung einfach durchschlagen mit sehr wenigen Ausnahmen.
Also wir waren bei available to the public for less than three years wann wir schon raus ne.
Genau also hier könnt ihr nichts mehr hochladen Leute.
Könnt ihr vergessen ne wir müssen immer gucken.
Die Kommentare.
Das eigentlich ganz schön was los die fünf Millionen unique monthly visitors da sind wir auch raus und dann annual turnover below ten million ja ok haben wir auch aber es hätte einheite schon gereicht ne.
Du weißt wir machen mehrstimmig und noch heute offen weißt du irgendwas was ich nicht weiß.
Nee aber okay wir waren eh schon raus bei den Wennebostel public verlässt in Trier.
So als wäre das noch nicht schlimm genug ist es halt auch so dass selbst wenn man alle drei Kriterien erfüllt man trotzdem angehalten ist klar rechtliche Regelung dieses Jahr haben wollte.
Ich muss noch mal gucken das ist echt also ich würde ganz kurz weil man nämlich alle drei ne du musst alle.
Man muss alle 3 erfüllen.
Weil du sobald du über 5 Millionen unique monthly visit hattest hast oder über 10 Millionen Umsatz oder über drei Jahre dabei bis musst du upload-filter haben ja im Zweifelsfall reist du,
am ehesten.
Das mit den fünf Millionen visitors oder das mit den drei Jahren das heißt du kannst eigentlich in dem Moment wo du deine wo du deine Domain registriert schon wissen in drei Jahren braucht die uploadfilter in spätestens drei Jahren brauche ich die uploadfilter.
Genau wenn ich sogar schon im nächsten Monat wenn er auf einmal extrem viel Erfolg hast weil du.
Wenn du von CEWE verlegt wurdest.
Signalr Copyrightverletzung.
Verkehr.
Aber selbst wenn man diese drei Kriterien noch erfüllt und im Prinzip frei wäre müsste man muss man immer noch irgendwie nachweisen dass man alles unternommen hat
um Copyright Verstöße zu verhindern indem man Hals sich Lizenzen von record labels Buch publizieren stockfoto database und so weiter
muss an die Regelung habe ich nicht so ganz verstanden was Sie damit konkret meint so oder so wenn man sozusagen auch noch gezwungen ist hier irgendwelche Abkommen zu
so pauschal Abkommen abzuschließen bringt das ja quasi jedes Unternehmen.
Jedes Unternehmen was eine Plattform anbieten will in eine extrem schlechte verhandlungs Basis weil du weißt alle sind dazu gezwungen und mehr oder weniger können dann die ganzen,
Lizenzgeber hier alle möglichen Bedingungen aufrufen weil die müssen ja und von daher
sind alle in Zugzwang und werden relativ wenig Handel andere Spielraum haben hier irgendwie günstige Lösung zu finden
mit anderen Worten wird alles teurer und scheiße und
wir müssen uns jetzt auf eine Zukunft einstellen wenn das durchkommt dass wir für alles was wir in Zukunft auf irgendwelchen Plattformen Posten quasi eine Genehmigung von irgendwelchen Zensur Maschinen zu bekommen.
Maschinen.
Nur die die die Jacke nachher die zensurmaschine sitzt von der Plattform Zwang verbunden dort und.
Die werde ich dann alle den Google da und will oder den Facebook da eintreten weil sie irgendwie nichts anderes haben und wenn die Maschine da Stunde kannst du nicht posten.
Dann kannst du es nicht pos.
Die-maus.de.
Ja dann war es das also vielleicht ist das ja auch wieder zur wieder auferstehen des Blogs wer weiß aber naja und damit sind halt eigentlich die copyright holder.
Mehr oder weniger jetzt zu die Geldgeber für das was überhaupt noch gepostet werden darf also es ist eigentlich nur
vollkommen absurde Situation und es könnte vor allem dazu führen weil das natürlich eine EU-Regelungen ist
dass wir jetzt wieder sehen wären so ähnlich über das schon bei der dsgvo gehabt haben aber bisschen mit anderen Vorzeichen das bestimmte Dienste in USA oder Asien sagen so,
ein Scheiß machen wir nicht mit Verblocken euch einfach dann halt ohne euch.
Noch ist alles nicht ganz komplett im Eimer denn,
für den Trilog ne müssen ja alle drei zustimmen die Kommission und vor allem noch das Parlament das heißt theoretisch gibt es jetzt noch die Möglichkeit dass das Parlament sich dagegen stellt.
Das ist allerdings ziemlich unwahrscheinlich wenn auch nicht vollkommen unmöglich,
nimmst du immer noch mit Axel Voss zu tun der da im Prinzip immer noch der Einpeitscher ist in dieser Thematik der wird sich sicherlich jetzt nicht gegen den Kompromiss stellen den seine Regierung gerade mit Frankreich geschlossen hat wird also nicht sonderlich hilfreich sein,
das ganze kann eigentlich jetzt nur von.
Parlamentariern aufgehalten werden die irgendwie merken dass er dann irgendwie zwei Monate später dann auch schon wieder Wahlen sind nachdem man das beschlossen hat,
und es könnte durchaus ein Aufschrei geben es könnte aber auch durchaus keinen Aufschrei geben von daher weiß ich noch nicht so ganz genau wie sehr man mit sowas Punkten kann weil wir wissen alle,
weil ich das wird am Ende bei der Europawahl nicht der entscheidende Faktor sein.
Es könnten also ob's der entscheidende Faktor ist ist vielleicht unklar aber ich könnte schon mal sagen dass ich mich sehr dafür interessieren würde.
Wenn ich bei der Europawahl mit mache wenn ich da Zeit habe ne.
Wo ich wo ich da klicke.
Ach du nix machst das halbe Wurzel oder was.
Cyberport Winkler Zeit souveränes nach Voting mache ich und.
Das wird das wäre für mich dann doch durchaus mal ausschlaggebend insofern ja jetzt hast du das ist irgendwie klar könnte sein dass es nicht ausschlaggebend ist für mich wäre es der.
Ja für mich.
Sondern andere schlechte Nachricht also es ist gut wenn alle die gegen Artikel 13 sind sind gut ja,
inzwischen ne kann man nicht kann man ja sagen wenn man sagt alle die dagegen sind sind gut das ist inzwischen ein,
großes Date mit weil sogar Erismann sind die EU Urheberrechtsreform jetzt,
inzwischen ab und sagt das hat am Ende mehr Nachteile als Vorteile also Bertelsmann ja das ist irgendwie das eine,
Bibiane Urheberrecht sich ausgedacht ja oder damit damit die Demokratie zu ruinieren hat er sich so ungefähr ausgedacht das und sagen.
Selbst die sind nicht mehr,
da dafür diese diese Reform so durchzusetzen ja und also mit der ist man ist einer der größten Medienkonzerne der Welt und,
für die soll das ja gemacht werden ja und jetzt hat sogar berelsmann in der den Kulissen zu den Parlamentariern passen könnte ich das bitte noch mal überlegen.
Das finden wir nicht besonders gut und wir lehnen das Ding komplett ab ja das ist schon wirklich.
Das ist Hardcore Fall mich wenn das ist gleich danach das einzige was mit diesem ganzen Prozess dann noch eine Rest Freude erzeugen kann dass die dann einfach mal merken dass sie mir sich mit ihrem ganzen Lobby Scheiße letzten Jahren
so dermaßen jetzt selber ins eigene Fleisch geschnitten haben nachhaltig langfristig.
Und keine Ahnung ob das langfristig dann wiederum zu irgendwelchen positiven Veränderungen führen kann keine Ahnung aber zumindest kavasam hehehe habt Elster.
Gesehen in der Richtlinie in der gesamt schon nicht mehr die ursprünglich angestrebte und von uns befürwortete Stärkung der Rechteinhaber und kreativen insbesonder Ticket 13,
naja wer ist man to the rescue.
Eine weitere Bastion der des Schutzes von Bürgerrechten ist in Deutschland natürlich neben.
Dem Bundesverfassungsgericht das Kartellamt kleiner Scherz am Rande.
Das Kartellamt hat das Kartellamt hat sich der Sitz des Facebooks angenommen in einem Verwaltungsverfahren das jetzt auch schon seit längerer Zeit läuft.
Und in diesem Verwaltungsverfahren ging es spezifisch um die,
die Datenzusammenführung die Facebook betreibt facebook hat ja in den letzten Jahren,
einige Unternehmen dazu gekauft hatte sich sogenannte Drittquellen gesichert das heißt also hat einfach seine Möglichkeiten Daten zu sammeln sehr stark ausgeweitet.
Und bei seiner Datensammlung.
Winkt es im Prinzip die Nutzer also beim Anmelden zwingt sie nutze diese Datensammlung auch über Drittquellen zu akzeptieren.
Alternativ können die Nutzerinnen und Nutzer eben auf die Nutzung verzichten.
Das heißt du bist gezwungen zu akzeptieren dass sie auch über Drittquellen Daten sammeln und diese zusammen.
Jetzt musste das Kartellamt sich also der Frage nähern ist Facebook marktbeherrschend.
Ist es also ein Mann Monopolist.
Handelt dieser Monopolist missbräuchlich unter Ausnutzung seiner marktbeherrschenden Stellung wenn er die Nutzer dazu verpflichtet dieser Sache zuzustimmen nur dass das ist ja Kat 1 Kat LR,
steam ist die Ausnutzung einer marktbeherrschenden Stellung wenn du eine marktbeherrschende Stellung hast ist das für das Kartellamt nicht unbedingt schlimm,
wenn du sie ausnutzt dann schon.
Deswegen die beiden Fragen und in diesem Verwaltungsverfahren sind sie zu dem Schluss gekommen erstens innerhalb von 12 Monaten.
Muss Facebook nun eine Wahlmöglichkeit für seine Nutzerinnen und Nutzer schaffen.
Sie müssen einwilligen oder ablehnen können.
Das Facebook diese Daten jetzt beispielsweise über WhatsApp und Instagram dritte Websites und Apps und so weiter sammelt und zusammen wenn Sie das ablehnen.
Dann müssen sie trotzdem Facebook nutzen können ja also das fratellanza wenn du diese Daten zusammen führst dann nur mit Einwilligung.
Diese Einwilligung muss.
Unabhängig davon sein ob man dein Dienst nutzt oder nicht weil das war ja das Problem dabei die missbräuchliche Nutzung von Facebook oder das Ausnutzen der marktbeherrschenden Stellung das heißt sie haben die Frage 1 ist Facebook marktbeherrschend im Prinzip mit ja beantwortet.
Und deswegen hat Facebook unter Ausnutzung seiner marktbeherrschenden Stellung missbräuchlich.
Aber sie sagen sie unterstellt sie untersagen damit nicht.
Diese plattformübergreifende Datensätze Datensammlung grundsätzlich also sein Facebook darf,
über Plattform verteilt Daten sammeln und zusammenführen Facebook,
darf muss aber dafür seine Nutzerinnen und Nutzer um Einverständnis bitten und wenn Sie diese Einverständnis nicht geben dann muss Facebook den trotzdem noch einen Dienst anbieten,
das ist das ist die Entscheidung des des Bundeskartellamtes hier Facebook sagt demgegenüber sowas wie.
Wir haben die datenschutzgrundverordnung und die gilt für alle gleich die Facebook lehnt,
außerdem oder insbesondere ab dass sie überhaupt eine marktbeherrschende Stellung haben nämlich sie haben ja harten Wettbewerb mit YouTube Twitter und snapchat was interessant ist.
Wenn du dir die Frage stellst was sind die Konkurrenten von von Facebook ne und Facebook sieht also YouTube Google,
als Konkurrenten weil da kann man Videos gucken und da gucken die Leute auch auf einen Bildschirm Twitter snapchat darüber kommunizieren Menschen,
und das nimmt Aufmerksamkeit von den Menschen finde das interessant das ist so ein bisschen sowas wie wenn wir jetzt sagen würden so.
Oder wenn wenn BMW sagen würde unsere Konkurrenten sind die Hersteller von Fernseher weil und die Hersteller von Sofas weil da sitzt die Leute auch und verbringen Zeit.
Ja
Andererseits stimmt es natürlich die sind also ich würde quasi sagen dieses wenn Facebook sagt unsere,
Konkurrenten sind andere riesige multinationale Unternehmen die auch was mit Internet machen dann ist das gleichzeitig auch die Definition einer marktbeherrschenden Stellung ja also sie konnten dir jetzt nicht sagen wir haben einen Konkurrenten der,
das gleiche macht 74.
Und dieses Unternehmen mit dem kämpfen wir tatsächlich um Nutzerzahlen insofern dass die Nutzung unserer Dienste.
Exklusiv ist
ja so Menschen sind entweder bei bei Google eingebunden oder bei Apple eingebunden oder so nein diese dieses Argument ist für Facebook glaube ich
sehr viel weiter hergeholt und ich würde auf jeden Fall der in der Überlegung
nachgehen dass Facebook eine marktbeherrschende Stellung hat ganz ganz klar ich finde auch dass sie die hieraus.
Das hängt aber ja also was ich so ein bisschen schwammig und schwierig auch einzuschätzen finde in dieser ganzen Debatte ist was genau ist hier eigentlich der Markt,
also,
wie definiert man Markt bei Autos und Fernseher mag das noch relativ einfach sein auch wenn das in Zukunft wahrscheinlich auch noch ganz glücklich sehen sein wird aber so diese leichter abtrennen barkeit von mark
ist schwierig und das sieht man schon diesem Vergleich ganz gut ne natürlich sind YouTube und Twitter und snapchat für sie Konkurrenten gar keine Frage.
Um die Aufmerksamkeit der Nutzerinnen und Nutzer.
Nierenversagen das geht auch noch konkreter.
So formulieren Sie es ja selber.
Ja so formulieren Sie selber aber eigentlich müssen Sie hier vielleicht ganz andere Wettbewerber machen die sehr wohl noch sehr viel mehr tun als
also
mehr tun als ihre hier genannten Konkurrenten ja da hast du was was ich in Russland hasse und wie Kontakte er oder hast du Weibo in China und keine Ahnung wahrscheinlich 18-20 andere Systeme die nicht auf den Zeiger habe aber insbesondere Vergleich mit China und wir hatten das ja auch schon mal angerissen.
Betrifft aber die dort das ist tschuldigung das betrifft ja nur mal die deutsche Kartellbehörden nicht dass es in China auch noch ein Unternehmen gibt
deutsche Kartellbehörde interessiert sich für den deutschen maximal den europäischen Markt und ob den 1 Anbieter beherrscht.
Gut ja das stimmt das ist da hast du natürlich recht nah aber trotzdem ist auch dieser Markt als solcher sehr schwer,
zu definieren also was genau ist dieser Markt wie bezeichnet man diese Tätigkeit was was wo wo fängt dein Internet Dienst an
und wo hört er auf und wie hart sind diese Grenzen das ist generell sehr schwierig zu beantworten nicht sagen dass Facebook keine keine beherrschende Stellung hat,
hat auf jeden Fall ne das hat aber sehr viel mehr mit dem Wesen des Dienstes zu tun als unbedingt jetzt mit dieser Markt Geschichte ist einfach so dass die Leute auch aus Facebook gar nicht raus können die im Prinzip,
Dirk werden kann was Facebook möchte weil es für diese Leute nicht ohne weiteres möglich ist woanders hinzugehen weil sie ja dann auch Ihr Netzwerk verlieren und das ist ja eigentlich das,
was die Leute da hält und das ist etwas was die klassische markttheorie sogar nicht wiedergibt.
Ich finde das also sie haben da eine schöne Grafik zu in ihrer in ihrer Pressemitteilung in der sie sagen
Menschen haben doch mehr Auswahl als je zuvor ja in den Wegen wie sie sich miteinander verbinden
Dinge miteinander teilen und so weiter ansagen dann hat hier messenger es gibt threema Signal skype telegram Viber und iMessage in dieser Grafik ja,
facebook hat auch ein ja dann sagen Sie hier soziale Netzwerke also senden symbolisiert mit zum,
mit so einem Megaphon also ihr wie Schrei etwas in die Welt und hoffe dass es jemand sieht sagen sie Twitter LinkedIn Medium,
Xing Jodel und WordPress dann haben Sie hier ein Herzchen sagen okay cupid Badoo lawu,
Jaumo Parship und tinder dann irgendwie Events sagen sie eventbrite Ticketmaster Meetup nebenan Eventim,
unten Auto nau du dann irgendwie verkaufen Ebay Kleinanzeigen Amazon Marketplace zu wish,
Kleiderkreisel wo war dann irgendwas mit Sternchen was einem Info gefällt oder sowas Foursquare Airbnb Yelp Google Maps TripAdvisor get your guide.
Nennen sie News Ding sein Apple News Flipboard Google News readly Twitter und reddit sind unsere Konkurrentin haben sie irgendwie ein wirklich etwas.
Ich weiß nicht was das Symbol darstellen soll aber da sind ihre Konkurrenten snapchat tik tok YouTube,
tikart Twitch und Pinterest ja also sie sagen der mir eine Reihe an Konkurrenten,
das Facebook marktbeherrschend ist siehst du daran dass die all das die mit all diesen Unternehmen konkurrieren und all diesen Unternehmen auch jeweils der größte Konkurrenz sind,
Twitter größter Konkurrent ist Facebook okay cupid größter Konkurrenz ist im Zweifelsfall dieses Facebook basierte tinder und,
das ist die marktbeherrschende Stellung dass sie überhaupt mit allen konkurrieren und dass sie bei allen diese Angebote haben.
Insofern würde ich sagen ihre Grafik entlarvt sie da so ein bisschen klar sie sagen es gibt viele mit denen wir konkurrieren aber wir sind im Prinzip der eine Riese der auf versucht den natürlich ihre Möglichkeiten irgendwie zu unterlaufen
wir versuchen in alle Richtungen zu wachsen und wird versuchen die Plattform zu sein wir versuchen das
Internet zu sein und das ist dann eben eine marktbeherrschende Stellung dann sagen sie ja wir wir befolgen die Vorgaben der dsgvo und.
Das ist natürlich jetzt hier so ein bisschen da haben sie natürlich die die die Vorgaben der dsgvo haben eben für alle gleich zu sein Ja und,
dann sagen Sie was ich sehr schön finde dass es ein Argument was sehr sehr viel in letzter Zeit missbraucht wird, beim nächsten Thema auch noch mal zu
die Dienste übergreifen informationsnutzung macht unsere Plattform besser und stärkt,
die Sicherheit dass er dich sein klar wenn wir hier zwei separate infrastrukturdienst uns weiter unterhalten und diese Information nicht zu erreichen Sicherheit zusammenführen dann gibt es theoretisch auch.
Mehr mehr Sicherheit für euch das Argument was der letzten Sendung ja glaube ich auch schon besprochen hatten ist diese Zusammenführung der der Messenger Ärzte sagen ok Hawaii WhatsApp so eine tolle Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung hat wollen wir jetzt
WhatsApp Instagram und Facebook Messenger mehr oder weniger in in 1 würfeln und genauso funktioniert halt das Ausbauen von von platform
und das Aufbauen von marktbeherrschenden Stellung und na ja am Ende,
Tja das zu dass das Ausbauen der marktbeherrschende Stellungen haben Kartellämter ja in der Regel selten verhindert.
Sie hat immer erst dann wenn die marktbeherrschende Stellung da war versucht da so ein bisschen,
zu regulieren und ziemlich genau dass das tun sie ja jetzt hier auch also großartiger Sieg ja wir werden demnächst also seit 2016 hat das Bundeskartellamt daran gearbeitet dass wir eben,
in einem Jahr dann 2020,
werden wir Facebook sagen können okay wir möchten das nicht zusammenführen oder wir möchten das Zusammenführen und dann wird Facebook sagen naja ok wenn es nicht zusammen für Service eben folgende folgende Nachteile haben aber prinzipiell unsere
Plattform noch nutzen können und dass dieser ganze dieser ganze Furz zieht dann irgendwie mit dem Wind davon ja also ich sehe da wirklich,
wenig wenig wenig wirklich wenig.
Du siehst wenig.
Ich sehe wie dich der mir jeder Sendung eine kurze positive Nachricht.
Die betrifft dieses Jahr dieses Jahr.
Die nachricht die gute Nachricht des Jahres.
Ich möchte Nachricht ist in diesem Jahr folgende es deutet sich an noch nicht in Details bisher liegen Dokumente nur vor dass der Bund auf die Forderung.
Das Länder die Hilfen die Sie im Rahmen des digitalpakt is bekommen zur Hälfte mit finanz.
Und sind langer Satz wir erinnern uns der Bund wollte Geld will Geld
in die Digitalisierung der Bildung stecken und hat das und an verschiedene Bedingungen geknüpft hat gesagt wenn wir euch Geld geben dann müsst ihr jeden eurer den wir euch nehmen müsst ihr quasi matchen mit 1 € von euch da ganz verschiedene,
Kritikpunkte und Probleme dran da hatten die Länder keine Lust drauf gab sogar ging soweit dass das bis in den in den grundgesetzlichen
Aspekt gegen weil der quasi dann der Bund durch das geben seines Geldes dem den Ländern Vorgaben macht wofür die ihr Geld ausgeben deshalb das,
eben auch verfassungsrechtliche Konsequenzen hätte es sieht danach aus dass der Bund davon ab Brück.
Und dann könnte das zu einer Einigung führen dann könnte dieser digitalpakt unter Umständen doch noch stattfinden,
freuen wir uns drauf wenn es tatsächlich.
So und dann kommen wir endlich glaube ich zum zum Thema dass wir schon vor ja ich glaube im letzten Jahr mal behandelt hatten als katharinen bei uns zu Gast war aber was nun auch wirklich.
So sehr laut und auf den auf den ersten Seiten diskutiert.
Und zwar ist das die Frage wenn jetzt also dass die 5g Netze in Deutschland gebaut werden und daran entfaltet sich diese Frage wollen wir in der Europäischen Union.
Zulassen dass dies mit Technik des chinesischen Herstellers war passiert.
Oder wollen wir das sogar unterbinden.
Oder anders gefragt wie wie schaffen es dann Telekom Ausrüster den Europa noch irgendwelche Aufträge zu zu Schatten sind.
Genau wie schaffen wir es wir schaffen das ist natürlich die eine der Fragen die sich dahinter verbirgt primär wird diese Debatte aber und das ist ja das was ich da so ein bisschen was mich daran sehr ärgert.
Über im Prinzip IT Sicherheit geführt wird immer unterstellt.
Nangina,
missbrauche oder sitzen was wieder für was steht der chinesischen Regierung sehr nahe chinesische Regierung engagiert sich im Bereich des
der Spionage und seit Wirtschaftsspionage und staatlicher Spionage und aus diesem Grunde vertrauen wir,
den Produkten aus dem Hause rauche nicht und zum Schutze der nationalen Sicherheit vor der Spionage,
des Chinesen ja dürfen wir unsere Zukunft Infrastruktur nicht mit diesem Produkt.
Mit Produkten dieses Herstellers baut sodass primär Argument was hier geführt wird es gibt natürlich noch einige weitere Argumente die da im Fahrwasser sind die nicht so schön öffentlichkeitswirksam sind wie z.b.
Das was du gerade nanntest wollen wir nicht lieber dass diese Netze bauen mit Herstellern,
Osteuropa um irgendwie die lokale Wirtschaft in irgendeiner Form zu zu stärken oder.
Emmett ist es vielleicht in 20 Jahren problematisch wenn wir hier im in der gigabit-gesellschaft angekommen sind und,
vorbereiten dass 2050 in allen Bussen Bayern WLAN vorgehalten wird ist noch als kleines ausstellungsstück,
ein Busfahrer.
Wo sie haben noch WLAN.
Gründen kann ich kann ich das Wlan weil haben ja hier hier ist das wie benutzt man das der da bräuchten sich jetzt 30 Jahre altes Telefon für.
Aber wenn sie als hätten.
Dann könntest du nutzen ja.
Können sich hier in sodanet gehen.
Genau so bist also aber so ein Akustikkoppler gereicht bekommt.
The Royal Bavarian net genau hier ok und.
Also quasi schneiden wir uns vielleicht strategisch von vom vom Fortschritt ab wenn wir jetzt ne wenn wenn die Information dass sich mit dieser Informationsgesellschaft durchsetzt und so ist das europäische wirtschaftlich opportun und so weiter.
Wenn wir da jetzt den den Schritt in die unmittelbare Zukunft schon mit mit chinesischer Zulieferung machen.
Ist das ist jetzt vielleicht klüger nur wenn wir das wenn wir das irgendwie versuchen Selbert.
Und das ist natürlich das sind alles Fragen zu denen man eine Meinung haben kann und ich würde mich natürlich auch freuen wenn Europa das mit der Digitalisierung nicht aufgeben würde,
Ja und man sagen wir doch okay wir versuchen mit den mit den europäischen Herstellern hier so etwas wie hinzukriegen und treffen hier eine wirtschaftspolitische,
Entscheidung dummerweise haben hat man natürlich in Europa und in den USA so die letzten Jahrzehnte.
Immer wieder den den freien Handel gepredigt ne und ihr wie gesagt wie wie wie großartig das ist wenn in einer globalisierten Welt ne Produkte exportiert und importiert werden und das ist für alle Seiten ja ganz besonders toll ist
bis jetzt irgendwie so langsam am Hintern am Horizont steht so na ja was wenn.
China irgendwann dann mal dieses Potenzial entfaltet mit dem wir es jetzt immer die letzten,
Jahrzehnte einerseits versorgt haben andererseits ist irgendwie noch geschafft haben China vor der vollständigen Entfaltung seines Potentials irgendwie abzuhalten er steht irgendwie,
am Horizont der China jetzt bald irgendwann einmal in vielen Bereichen der Innovationen ganz einfach,
die Supermacht wird ja die haben.
So eine echt ganz gute Aussicht und das was sie aktuell bauen an Städten und so weiter das sind jetzt schon Leistungen die du in den in den USA und in Europa einfach nicht siehst die sind jetzt einfach auf der,
Überholspur.
Natürlich kannst du nach soundsoviel Jahren Neoliberalismus und Globalisierung nicht mehr so einfach zu einem zu einem Wirtschaft Protektionismus zurück klar dort kannst du zu wie Donald Trump machen geht relativ einfach,
funktioniert natürlich politisch nicht ganz so gut und vor dem Hintergrund denke ich muss man das sehen was mich an der ganzen Debatte nur ärgert.
Wie fachfremd also wie wie die sachfremd die geführt wird es gibt wenn man sie jetzt mal die Argumente anschaut.
Ausgerechnet bei WoW gibt es keine erhärteten.
Hinweise dass diese Hardware und Software diese Produkte für die Spionage eingesetzt wurden bei den amerikanischen Herstellern hast du das sehr wohl,
wenn sie wenn du dich jetzt also hinstellt und sagt ja hier wir wollen noch bei Abkommen von China haben damit wir alle Produkte kaufen,
da sagen die sogar die europäischen Hersteller schon ja nee sowas da machen wir nicht mit,
ja also wenn es wenn du bei dem Argument der Sicherheit bleibst dann müsstest du als allererstes den Kram aus amerikanischer Produktion,
bei dir rauswerfen da würde aber natürlich keiner drauf kommen eigentlich kommt noch nicht mal jemand darauf denen denen Einlass bei Abkommen ab zu verlangen und das ist doch ein bisschen komisch.
Ja vor allem glaube ich auch nicht dass man ernsthaft von der chinesischen Regierung erwarten konnte das nun los bei Abkommen und wie jemals durchkommen würde wenn man das schon mit bösartig hinbekommen hat.
Jacken aber hat's in inmitten mit den USA nicht hinbekommen und ich bin ich bin mal gespannt was was ihr wie die die anderen europäischen Hersteller dazu sagen ne abgesehen davon muss ich mal also die.
Also jetzt irgendwie so zu überhaupt also ich mal wie funktioniert als die Sicherheit bei diesen Geräten ja IT Sicherheit oder Schwachstellen bei diesen Geräten funktionieren,
oder Sonne wie würde Spionage funktionieren Spürnase Spionage würde funktionieren über Sicherheitslücken Spionage funktioniert nicht darüber das war jetzt irgendwie was weiß ich,
die die geheime zerstörungs Backdoor für die chinesische chinesische meine Güte ist hier offenbar mit zuviel Co.
Höchstens aufgeregt war.
Die chinesische Regierung Backdoor Funktionalitäten einbauen als würde er darüber funktionieren dass sie a.
Als Schwachstellen zu erklärende.
Zugriffsmöglichkeiten absichtlich einbauen die sogenannten backdorf ja also baust deine Backdoor nicht mehr so dass jeder der sie sieht sagt a-ok wenn man hier was weiß ich Nutzername Chi Jin Ping.
Passwort Kommunismus forever eingibt hat man Vollzugriff
das wäre eine Backdoor eine Bachlor wäre er sowas wie hier ist ein Programmierfehler wenn das Passwort so lang ist und da gibt's hier ein Buffer Overflow und wenn man dann hier einmal zieht dann,
kann man auf einmal Zugriff auf das Gerät bekommen bedauerlicher Fehler wenn den jemand findet,
da wird er natürlich oja oh meine Güte gut dass sie das gemeldet haben hier ist hier bug-bounty den mach mal jetzt weg so so baust du heutzutage.
Ebenbeck doors die ihm dann aussehen wie Bucks wenn sie jemand findet und.
Das was aussieht wie Bugs und Kontrolle über diese Geräte,
ermöglicht das findest du bei Cisco am laufenden Band das findest du bei anderen Herstellern am laufenden Band das ist jetzt ewig einen kein einzig,
das Merkmal von wow wow das da die Qualität irgendwie nennenswert besser oder schlechter wäre als bei den anderen Herstellern. 2.
Problematisch sehe ich viel eher die Integration dieser Geräte also viel weniger den Zulieferer als den Integrator denn diese Netze werden gebaut von,
unterschiedlichen.
Zulieferern du baust dir nicht dein Netz aus 100% Whey Whey oder 100% NSN oder wen auch immer du dir da reingestellt hast sondern du nimmst,
verschiedene Sonnen einen sogenannten vendor Mix in der Regel sind das irgendwie soll ich mal zwei oder drei der großen Zulieferer.
Oben nämlich gegenseitig die preislich gegeneinander ausspielen zu können
da damit du nämlich das übrigens hier war hat bei uns schon den Fuß in der Tür dann sparst du natürlich
nicht nur erstes das Geld was du daran Spaß dass du die günstiger Anwalt Produkte gekauft hast sondern auch noch das Geld was du dadurch warst dass du die anderen runter handelst mit der Drohung den Anteil von Mauer in deinem Netz zu erhöhen.
Dauer auch immer.
Warum ist das interessant.
Technische Heterogenität natürlich auch zu haben und wenn jetzt irgendwie eine platforma komplett den Berg runter geht weil irgendwas ganz grundsätzliches verkackt wurde dass man dann eben nicht komplett nackt dasteht.
Jetzt kommt aber der. Die müssen miteinander operieren ne die müssen das Netz ist.
Vollständig interoperabel dafür gibt's ja nun mal dafür werden ja Standards geschrieben die daneben 2G 3G 4G heißen Prinz grundsätzlich kannst du eigentlich ne dir die unterschiedlichen Netzwerkkomponenten von unterschiedlichen Herstellern,
kaufen da hinstellen integrieren Test,
paar Monate laufen lassen und dann werden die schon irgendwie grob miteinander funktionieren die funktioniert funktioniert natürlich nicht so hundertprozentig da muss dann bisschen muss dann ordentlich eingeölt werden aber das wird natürlich auch mit der entsprechenden Sorgfalt gemacht.
Aber hier von der kritischen Infrastruktur sprechen die jede Minute viel Geld verdient und viel kritische.
Last aushält und für viele Dinge die da draußen funktionieren eben eine eine wichtige Basis.
Und und so und so findet man ja überhaupt erst bestimmte Fehler wenn du inhomogenes Netz hast wo alles nur von dem Hersteller ist ne dann
das hat der Hersteller auch schon getestet dass die alle miteinander klarkommen das heißt aber nicht dass nicht in irgend einer kritischen Situation mal alles komplett auseinander fällt und das fällt dir natürlich sehr viel früher auf wenn du sowieso schon unterschiedliche Hersteller miteinander passt
die ihm nicht auch quasi alle dieselben Fehler haben sollen jeder andere Fehler hat
die sich dann gegenseitig triggern und dann fällt dir das eben auch aus und das wird dann eben auch zum stabileren System.
Also Oma den den den Grad der Sorgfalt zu zu grob zu skizzieren den so ein durchschnittlicher europäischer Hersteller da walten lässt die haben ein sogenannter Testbed in diesem Testbed.
Steht im Prinzip jedes Gerät von allen Herstellern was die irgendwie in ihrem Netz haben.
Mindestens einmal wenn ich in der Regel sogar zweimal damit sie seamless irgendwie Software-Version miteinander vergleichen können und so weiter und da prüfen die.
Quasi jede Veränderung diese an dem Netz machen jedes Update und so weiter prüfen Sie dort vorher unterziehen das eine,
ungarisch langen Test mit allen möglichen Handgeräten Endgeräten und so weiter bevor Sie irgendeine Erinnerungen an dem an dem life-ness machen und,
der Willis heikel ist dann so durchschnittlich würde ich sagen jedes halbe Jahr kommt wird jetzt vielleicht seinen Armen Software-Update hochgefahren ja
oder gesagt dass a-ok mit dem nächsten Release Heike ziehen wir die Huawei Komponente XY auf Softwareversion soundso aktivieren folgendes Feature machen folgende Änderung dann wird das ein halbes halbes Jahr dauert das mit testing und so wie ist das dann ihr wann im Live jetzt ausgeräumt wird
und hinter dem Entwicklungsstand des Herstellers sind wir dann ungefähr ja sagen wir mal also.
Im Durchschnitt irgendwas zwischen anderthalb und zweieinhalb Jahren hinterher,
ja was ich jetzt so kenne von den unterschiedlichen Netzbetreibern was einfach auch nur zeigt dass sie ihm sehr konservativ und sorgfältig sind,
a-ok der Hersteller hat jetzt was neues geliefert und wenn ihr sagen wir wollen ein neues Feature ausrollen ne da müssen natürlich auch alle drei Hersteller auf den Stand bringen.
Dieses Feature zu unterstützen und jetzt kommt der interessante. Insbesondere bei Huawei ist es so dass die.
Wenn du jetzt da wir sind auf Softwareversion sonst und wir wollen jetzt folgendes folgende Funktionalität für unser Netz haben also ihrem wir brauchen eine,
wir brauchen jetzt eine Suppe von euch die Folgen des Candy irgendwie in folgender Weise inter operiert dann kriegst du das von one way auf jeden Fall.
Und im Zweifelsfall auch so ein so ein bisschen custom ja dass sie also sagen,
das jetzt nicht sagen okay du musst auf Version 13.7 gehen da gab da gibt's dieses Feature mit folgender Konfiguration sondern die haben im Prinzip im Repository wo sie dann dafür sorgen dass die Software die du bekommst
bei dir auch so ein bisschen so ein custom-built ist ne also wenn du dir es jetzt aus als Softwarehersteller vorstellst die haben halt nicht einfach ja okay du musst auf Office,
2013 Version 9.8 10.27 gehen sondern die haben unter Umständen halt auch so ein bisschen so ein Custom Feature für dich und mergimtar man anderen branch rein aus einer höheren Version oder oder oder.
Und jetzt kommen die und sagen wir wollen euren Quellen Quelltext sehen ja wird was die Garage wozu die garantierten nicht in der Lage sind das ist jetzt das weiß ich nicht das,
vermute ich aber sind,
für alle diese verschiedenen Geräte die sie da haben diese davor halten und Software Version und so reproduzierbare Bild.
Anzubieten also den Beleg dir zugeben dass der Quelltext die sie dir gezeigt haben den du dir deine anschau.
Dass der auch für dich läuft.
Dass der auch wirklich läuft und die werden dir sicherlich nicht sagen ach ja hier ist dein Repo,
du machst einfach make install
und dann dann pushen wir das auf deinen Netz das wird halt so nicht sein wenn jetzt wenn jetzt dieses Angebot verlangt wird legt eure Milliarden Zeilen Quelltext die Tausende von unterschiedlichen Komponenten aus letztes geben bitte beim BSI zur Einsicht hin.
Das kostet die ein müdes arschrunzeln das zu machen oder es ist einfach nur absolute absoluter Symbolpolitik Quatsch.
Also da bin ich nicht besonders glücklich damit wie diese Diskussion über tatsächliche,
Vektors oder IT Sicherheit hier gefühlt geführt werden soll denn wenn es wirklich so wäre dass die Huawei Produkte irgendwelche Backdoors haben dann ist das was den.
Den Angreifern am Ende hilft die Kontrolle zu übernehmen,
über das gesamte Netz in dem Huawei im Zweifel maximal 30 bis 40% gestellt hat
wenn sie dann sagen wir kontrolliert das gesamte Netz dafür brauchen sie das wissen das nämlich aus der Integration kommt wohl nämlich sowas ist wie Passwort test test.
Also für die Sicherheit wäre jetzt wirklich sehr wenig getan indem man auf einen Anbieter verzichtet oder nicht,
sicherheitsrelevant ist das wissen was die Anbieter bei der Integration bekommt da bekommen sie nämlich dann das Wissen über das gesamte Netz.
Teilweise wird ja sogar der Betrieb des Netzes outgesourct aber das ist noch ein anderes Thema und,
da bekommen sie das wissen was sie dann eben auch brauchen um den Teil den die anderen zu liefern
Geschirr gestellt haben mitzuübernehmen also aus sicherheits Perspektive ist dieses ist diese Debatte wirklich sehr fehlgeleitet aus wirtschaftlicher Perspektive,
und das ist ja eigentlich auch der Auslöser nämlich hier diese Donald Trump her wir schmeißen den Chinesen raus Rhetorik.
Da würde ich mir jetzt mal mangels Kompetenz ein Urtheil verkneifen,
aber das ist das was hier gerade die Debatte ist die geführt mal wieder am Thema vorbei.
Ja die gelbe Gefahr hatten das ja auch schon mal vielleicht an der Stelle wäre die Sendung noch nicht gehört hat die wir noch nicht mit katharinen aufgenommen haben unser Spezial vom Ende des Jahres
ich schaue gerade mal was die Sendungsnummer wa.
280 Wolken Sensorik interessante Einblicke in das Verhältnis zu China.
Also Fazit noch mal zu der Ware Debatte wenn wir jetzt wenn wir will no-spy-abkommen ab verlangen dann sollten wir das auch allen anderen ab verlangen mal gucken ob die mitmachen.
Und bei denen haben wir nämlich Hinweise dass sie spionieren
Baureihe gibt's das bisher nicht und ich wäre echt gespannt wenn du wenn wenn man dieses wenn man diese Sachen mit dem North bei Abkommen jetzt mal reißt ja das finde ich eigentlich ganz spannend so sage ok B5 geht das nur bauernwehr no-spy-abkommen macht,
und dann wirst du nämlich am Essen 55 kg mit 100% vorbei bauen warten müssen weil das offenbar die einzigen sind die die Bereitschaft signalisiert haben sich einem no-spy-abkommen zu beugen wenn ich auf jeden Fall sehr amüsant.
Sommer.
Keine Ahnung ich habe Angst dass zu viele Leute zuhören würden und dann fliegen wir raus.
Dann früh wenn wir raus wir kriegen dann nämlich Internetverbot,
es ist tatsächlich so dass es irgendwie so eine so eine sehr skurrile Thematik die ich immer mal wieder gehört habe aber mir auch immer so ein bisschen noch ihr wenigstens eine.
Es gibt in jedem Land eine Landeszentrale für Medien und es ist tatsächlich in Deutschland so dass.
Ist bestimmte Regulationen für Rundfunk gibt und wenn du regulation für Rundfunk hast dann hast du dich auch eine Definition.
Was Rundfunk ist und nicht jeder darf Rundfunk machen dafür gibt's nicht eben die Landesmedienanstalten.
Und jetzt ist es offenbar so.
Dass die in zumindest in Bayern aber ich glaube bundesweit sogar die.
Tiere die Definition vorher zumindest in der Praxis wenn du regelmäßig sendest.
Und dabei stets mehr als 500 Zuschauer erreichst dann benötigst du.
Eine Lizenz für deinen Rundfunk artiges Angebot z.b. deine Streams.
Starkes Ding regelmäßig.
Schon länger Diskussion heilig in der Podcast Landschaft wird aber auch alle durch weitgehend ignoriert.
Ja es ist eigentlich mein Mann kann sich aber kann jetzt auch nicht jeden scheiß auf jeden Scheiß in die aufspringen ne
meinte das kommt halt natürlich aus einer aus ich kann verstehen in einer Zeit wo Menschen irgendwie mit Funkgeräten und so weiter unter der Ältere poliert werden musste und so dumb da musst du sowas mal irgendwie definiert werden.
Und jetzt ist folgendes passiert bei uns.
Schon ab und an mal erwähnt wurde der sogenannte Drachenlord.
Mobbing viel und Youtuber aus einem Dorf in Bayern.
Emskirchen oder so.
Ja irgendwo wohnt er so und der macht er macht er YouTube YouTube Streams YouTube Videos und,
es ist ihm gelungen damit tatsächlich seinen Lebensunterhalt,
irgendwie zu bestreiten durch Spenden die irgendwie während seiner Streams da wohl gesammelt werden.
Am durch andere monetarisierungs Plattform verliert links und so weiter hat es dieser junge Mann geschafft sich ein ausreichend großes Publikum bereitzustellen,
dass er ist dass es ihm gelingt damit seinen Lebensunterhalt zu bestreiten,
auch hat er ist es passiert dass er sich einen beträchtlichen Anteil Menschen
aufgebracht hat die ihm immer wieder irgend welches Unheil wünschen die hatten das hier in mehreren Sendung auch mal am Rande gestreift ich glaube eine hatte den schönen Namen Hey Siri lösch dich.
Hey Alexa lösch dich wissen wir jetzt auch noch sagen damit dann wirklich der Blackout in den Wohnzimmern der Hörerschaft passiert.
Ok Google lösch dich.
Ok Google okay.
Alle Zylinder löscht euch.
Und um den gibt es eben eine ganze Reihe von.
Unschönen Phänomen wo Leute dieses Tochter besuchen wo Leute in den irgendeiner Form terrorisieren weil sie genug Zeit haben und ein so.
Erbärmliches Leben führen dass sie keinen anderen Inhalt darin finden als irgendwie so ein.
Sehr sonderbaren Menschen irgendwo in einem bayrischen Dorf zu terrorisieren eine der Ideen die jemandem dabei kam war er ich könnte doch einfach mal.
Bei der mal bayrischen lehrt Landeszentrale für neue Medien im einen Antrag auf Lizensierung als.
Rundfunk irgendwie stellen,
in der Erwartung dass dieser Antrag abgelehnt wird und genau das ist passiert die haben also irgendwie es wurde also der gute Drachenlord sagt jetzt diesen Antrag hat er selber nicht gestellt.
Die Landesmedienanstalt sagt naja der ist bei uns eingegangen wir haben dann weil er unvollständig war weitere
Unterlagen verlangt diese wurden aber trotz Nachfrage nicht nachgereicht deswegen haben wir gar nicht weiter geprüft sondern die das Erteilen dieser Lizenz verwehrt und damit eben auch dem,
diesem einen spezifischen Youtuber jetzt das Recht entzogen diese streame dieses Fenster anzubieten und durchzuführen die für ihn aus irgendwelchen.
Ergründen eben ein wichtiger eine wichtige Einkommensquelle waren.
Bist ja auch ein geiler DDoS ne ich meine das hält ja noch nicht mal selber den Antrag soll irgendjemand anders macht dass das unvollständig und dann wird einem das irgendwie untersagt das ist ja wohl auch mega krass also.
Es ist also ja das ist kannst du wahrscheinlich in vielen Situationen tun.
Kann.
Ärgerlich wenn man sich überlegt zu wessen Spiel bei sich diese bayerische Landeszentrale für neue Medien da macht.
Ich bin irgendwie nicht also sowieso ich habe mir da mal das angeschaut der hat so einen Drachenlord react Video veröffentlicht wo ich denke dass kann man sich durchaus mal anschauen.
Woher sie meinte seine Sicht.
Auf das was er da geschaffen hat und auf das was ihm widerfährt schildert ja ich weiß es gibt viele Leuten viele Äußerungen die der irgendwie online getätigt hat die jetzt irgendwie Kritik
würde ich sind es gibt eine Reihe an Maßnahmen die,
bei ihm durchgeführt wurden die aber mindestens ebenso indiskutabel sind sie diese Belästigungen vor Ort das Eindringen irgendwie in seinem Privatleben und was nicht alles.
Und seine Perspektive darauf ist ebenso das was er da hat dieses Drachenlord Ding das hat er sich selber aufgebaut das hat er.
Genauso wie du dir die Metaebene selber aufgebaut hast und wir gemeinsam hier diesen Podcast aufgebaut haben ist es ihm weiterhin gelungen.
Dafür irgendwie damit irgendwie Geld zu verdienen warum auch immer sich die Leute das angucken unter welchen Bedingungen und welchen Beweggründen die ihm da irgendwie Geldspenden er hat es,
geschafft sich da selber etwas aufzubauen weiterhin was ich sehr krass finde und was ich sehr berücksichtigen swert finde ist dass er sagt der,
scheiß der mir hier jeden Tag angetan wird mit.
Irgendwelchen Arschgeigen die das Haus belagern irgendwelchen Menschen die sich über mich lustig machen im Internet das.
Von den meisten Leuten die in der Theorie sieren im Zweifelsfall keiner einen Tag ausgehalten.
Das muss ich auch mal sagen dass das hat da hat er recht das hätte ich mir also da hätte ich früher wahrscheinlich mit dem youtuben aufgehört wenn wenn ich einen dermaßen den Gegenwind bekommen hätte.
Und jetzt wird ihm das genommen diese Stream sind für ihn in irgendeiner Form.
Eben monetarisierungs relevant ich glaube seine seine Haupt,
Einnahmequelle ich habe nie so ein Stream gesehen ich glaube dass die auch eben wieder von handeln dass er irgendwie,
dass man der quasi live auf das Geschehen einen Einfluss nehmen kann indem man da Geld spendet ich habe leider ich habe mir fehlt die Zeit für sowas so aber ich denke das ist sollte,
für uns alle wichtig und erhaltbar bleiben dass wir diese Möglichkeiten.
Des Ausdrucks des dezentralen Ausdrucks und der Öffentlichkeit Gewinnung und von mir aus auch der Gestaltung von Geschäftsmodellen in diesem Rahmen.
Haben und deswegen finde ich das echt äußerst bedauerlich I dass das hier.
Getan wurde um diesen Menschen zu Schaden in zu sein auch finanziell zu Schaden 21 aber auch dass wir überhaupt noch so antiqui,
Antiquare Gesetze haben die wo jetzt irgendwie so eine komische Landeszentrale von der ich vorher nicht gehört habe in der Lage ist irgendwie Youtuber seine Livestreams zu Fabienne.
Nur weil du noch nichts von der Landesmedien zentrale gehört das heißt es ja nicht dass sie kein Existenzrecht hat allem ich will.
Die hatten von mir aus ein Existenzrecht ja aber ich denke der YouTube Livestreams haben genauso ein Existenzrecht,
und von mir aus kann die bayerische Landeszentrale für neue Medien das machen,
wozu sie gedacht war aber es ist relativ eindeutig dass diese das dass es sich hier um eine Entscheidung handelt die nur diese diese Person betrifft von mir aus sollen die.
Im Rahmen eines demokratischen Prozesses das Streamen auf YouTube verwenden von mir soll die YouTube verbieten völlig in Ordnung ja also wenn das eben in einem nachvollziehbaren für alle gleichen Prozess stattfindet aber wenn es ihr wie eine Person,
angeschwärzt wird bei dieser Landesmedien zentrale und die dann irgendwie sagen ja ok dann verbieten bei dem das jetzt ja und andere Personen ist geschafft haben sich irgendwie beliebter zu halten so dass es keine Beschwerden über die gibt,
dann ist doch hier offenbar nicht das was geschieht ist doch dann offenbar nicht nicht das was im im Sinne des Rechts hier versucht wurde zu schaffen.
Also ich bin mit Kinder mal kurz hier die Bedienung ist die Thema von dieser bayerischen Landeszentrale für neue Medien die haben eine Infoseite zum Thema Internet-TV ja und ich breche gleich mal anmerken mir kommt diese ganze Story noch etwas,
merkwürdig vor weil letztlich haben die ja nur gesagt dass sie quasi aus formalen Gründen weil Unterlagen fehlten sagen.
Keine Genehmigung erteilt haben ob dass sich automatisch in ein Verbot überhaupt umrechnet
ist mir ehrlich gesagt gerade nicht so ganz klar wenn man aber immer schaut was ehrlich die Kriterien sind ja also für bundesweite Angebote ist eine Zulassung erforderlich,
wenn folgende Kriterien erfüllt sind da gibt's dann genau eins nehme ich es handelt sich um Rundfunk.
Und dann kommt die Definition nach derzeit geltenden gesetzlichen Regelungen handelt es sich um Rundfunk wenn ein Angebot entlang eines Sendeplan verbreitet.
Und journalistisch redaktionell gestaltet wird und das Angebot wird linear verbreitet,
können Nutzer,
nicht selbst bestimmen wann das Angebot startet oder endet liegt am lineare Verbreitung voran Beispiel dafür ist der Livestream da trifft natürlich zu und dann ist noch von mehr als 500
Port Greve lustigerweise das Angebot ist technisch für mindestens 500 potentielle Nutzer gleichzeitig erreichbar und spricht hier von parallelen Zugriffsmöglichkeiten oder Porz
mit anderen Worten das ist etwas was sie quasi auf jeden Streaming-Server heutzutage zutrifft,
was die technischen Rahmenbedingungen betrifft aber wahrscheinlich auch so gut wie gar keinen solange du nicht einen Sendeplan hast und das ganze journalistisch-redaktionell gestaltete wird,
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass der Drachenlord ein Sendeplan hat oder irgendwie nennenswert nachweisen kann hier irgendwas schon lustig zu gestalten.
Kann ich leider mangels Kenntnis nicht sagen inwiefern das gescheiten Sendeplan hatte aber wohl also das ist das wird angekündigt wann da die nächste Sendung ist aber du hast natürlich recht sie haben.
Diesen Antrag.
Einfach nicht zu Ende führen können sagen aber er hat eine eine Zulassung ist erforderlich und entweder sie sind auf der auf der Position dass eine Zulassung erforderlich ist und dann teilen Sie in die nicht und dann ist eben Schluss.
Und sie ihren Tweet lese ich so viel neue Medien Landesanstalt für neue Medien.
Die sagen sie haben keine weitere inhaltliche Prüfung vorgenommen aber.
Der Livestream ist aus formalen Gründen untersagt worden.
Format ja so sagen von mal du hast den Antrag gestellt der Antrag ist unvollständig deswegen nett das ist ja auch verständlich dass du musst Bürokratie natürlich funktionieren wenn jemand einen Antrag stellt.
Dieser Antrag ist unvollständig und du kannst jetzt über den Antrag nicht entscheiden dann ist klar bist du entschieden hast,
ist es natürlich verboten es erkannt ja auch nicht sagen wieso ich habe doch ich habe doch hier einen Reisepass beantragt,
so in einem unvollständigen Antrag also bin ich jetzt Bürger der Bundesrepublik Deutschland oder sonst hast ne und jetzt ein blödes Beispiel zu nehmen
und deswegen sagen sie aus formalen Gründen ist dieser Leistung wird untersagt von man kann jetzt ihm natürlich wünschen dass er den Nachweis zu führen in der Lage ist dass es sich nicht um ein schnelles Tisches Angebot handelt und dass er,
das redaktionell nicht.
Aufbereitet oder so trotzdem hat er zumindest jetzt für längere für die Zeit bis er das irgendwie in der Lage ist das dazu schaffen sie jetzt auch irgendwie ich weiß jetzt nicht genau wie da seine Fähigkeiten sind sich mit so einer
formal Bürokratie auseinanderzusetzen hat er da jetzt irgendwie diesen.
Diesen Schaden davon finde ich irgendwie wurde in den Kommentaren erwähnt dass das berichtenswert ist und das ist es im Zweifelsfall auch weil das ja wirklich hier so ein bisschen die Absurdität.
Darstaed.
Danalock Bundespolitiker Bibliothek der Absurdität.
Verbleiben beim ein bisschen absurden Ding.
Ausnahmsweise.
Es war ja klar dass nach dem ganzen Promi doxing.
Der ganze norbit Array musste ja jetzt auch etwas passieren,
haben ja auch schon den letzten Folgen vieles behandelt was in Reaktion oder in Kontext mit diesem Promi doxing gesetzt wurde,
finde ich alles trifft dazu jedenfalls gibt es jetzt am.
Freitag den 15. Februar eine Debatte über einen Antrag von FDP.
Und Linken.
Federführend oder oder im Auto bestimmen für diesen Antrag ist aber die FDP das ist ganz interessant weil wenn ihr zu einer Debatten Woche ist im Bundestag.
Dann gibt es da quasi nach Proporz verteilt die Debatten Plätze also die Oppositionsparteien haben quasi weniger.
Mögliche weniger Plätze die,
ein Thema in den Bundestag einzubringen das können jetzt eben wie CDU und SPD am besten weil die da eben auch am meisten die beiden Plätze haben dann folgt irgendwie die anderen Parteien.
Linke hat eben nicht nicht ganz so viele Debatten Plätze die Opposition muss also mit ihren Debatten Plätzen,
aufhalten also Tagesordnungspunkt hat jetzt eben am Freitag die FDP und die hat einen,
relativ ausführlichen Antrag oder relativ ausführlich acht Seiten,
der ist deshalb relativ ausführlich weil er jetzt keine Juristerei enthält Nase ein ein Gesetz Änderungsantrag wenn du eine Seite wenn du einen Satz im Gesetz ändern willst du das sofort drei Seiten weil Begründung und so weiter dieser Antrag ist jetzt nur so ein Debattenbeitrag wo leben Aufforderungen drin stehen
und das steht wieder sowas wie der mit der Bundestag möge beschließen die IT Sicherheit ist die Achillesferse des Informationszeitalters Bedenken first.
Second Digitalisierung und so weiter und.
So und haben sie eine Reihe Anforderungen er,
time teilweise welche die wir ja auch schon seit längerer Zeit in diesem Programm gebetsmühlenartig fordern insbesondere betrifft es die Rolle des BSI,
soll also aus der Zuständigkeit des BMI herausgelöst werden um eben,
unabhängig von den sonstigen Interessen und Interessenkonflikten des BMI im Sinne der IT Sicherheit agieren zu können soll eine zentrale Meldestelle werden.
Für Schwachstellen und da so eine Art war nur Bilitis equities Prozess ermöglichen.
Und eben entweder Sicherheits selbst schließen oder wenn sie im Zuständigkeitsbereich Dritter liegen diese zu informieren.
Und wenn alte Sicherheitsvorfälle stattfinden dann soll das BSI eben auch mit dem Bundes.
Wie hat seine Daten Bundesbeauftragten für Datenschutz und Informationsfreiheit von Anfang an zusammen arbeiten und so weiter haben also relativ viel sich um die Sicherheit,
kümmert sich hier nur ein sehr kleiner.
Sehr kleine Zusammenfassung bemerkenswert fand ich noch sie sagen ok wir möchten bitte,
im Urheberrechtsklage steht wird das Reverse Engineering also dass das Untersuchen der Funktion Funktion von proprietären Protokollen oder Produkt,
also das mit dem Ziel des Auffinden ist und Schließens von Sicherheitslücken erfolgt es zulässig ist das war das was wir hier schon in,
vor einigen Sendungen bei dem Gesetz für das zum Schutz des Geschäftsgeheimnisses kritisiert haben dass es da droht,
unter die Räder zu kommen.
Zweiten sagen sie wollen gerne das im 202a StGB Davis und die Computerkriminalität
die Strafbarkeit an die Intention der Handlung geknüpft wird um sicherzustellen dass mit dem Ziel der Schließung von Sicherheitslücken
oder zu Zwecken der fort und Weiterbildung quasi Zugriff auf,
Daten und Informationssysteme genutzt er erlangt werden darf auch sehr wichtig und.
Dann sagen sie noch wollen bis 20 Uhr Skoda und so weiter und sie sagen dir die Einführung des neuen Start des Tatbestands des digitalen Hausfriedensbruchs von sie ablehnen sie haben eine relativ haben jetzt mal so ihren kompletten,
Cyber Forderung dort eingebracht.
Und die Linke hat er gesagt wir würden gerne auch noch was da dran heften nämlich mal was relativ pragmatisch ist,
der Deutsche Bundestag fordert die Bundesregierung auf ein Gesetz vorzulegen welches die Verpflichtung zur Angabe von privaten Wohnadressen im Impressum von Websites
von Privatpersonen Kleinunternehmen und so weiter im privat betriebene Blogs und ehrlich im Streich.
Und optional stattdessen die Angabe der ladungsfähigen Adresse über die Benennung eines ZW einer Zustellungsbevollmächtigten ermöglicht Hintergrund der Idee ist natürlich,
das was wir vor zwei Sendung glaube ich besprochen haben diese doxing Angriffe auf Menschen die sich in irgendeiner Form.
Politisch äußern die Metaebene unterliegt einer Impressumspflicht und
auch ich und so auch viele andere die sich irgendwie politisch äußern und da gab es ja eben jetzt vor kurzem wie bei uns besprochen diese Liste wo offenbar rechte eine Sammlung von Adressen.
Am innenpolitisch nicht genehmer Privatpersonen und Privatadressen.
Geführt haben und diese veröffentlicht haben und da in diesem Rahmen kommt das natürlich regelmäßig zu,
Belästigungen zu Angriffen auf diese Person von irgendwelchen.
Wieder mal Leuten mit zu viel Zeit.
Und das betrifft natürlich insbesondere er Leute die nicht ohnehin schon in der Öffentlichkeit stehen und gerade die sind aber natürlich durch diese Impressumspflicht gezwungen,
sich in die Öffentlichkeit zu stellen und quasi zu sagen ja hier ist der Ort an den Du mich regelmäßig auf findest wenn du mir auf die Fresse hauen willst.
Und dass das gilt natürlich auch für die Registrierung von Domains willst ein bisschen mit der dsgvo was,
dann gemacht werden sollte aber ich höre auch nach wie vor dass es jetzt relativ problemlos möglich ist my herauszufinden auf jeden eine Domain registriert ist und
diesen Antrag finde ich eigentlich natürlich ebenfalls.
Unterstützend und reflektionswert weil wir eben insbesondere die die kleineren pennerin Menschen die jetzt ohne großen Hintergrund ohne großen finanziellen Hintergrund ihr welche Angebote machen hier
verpflichten sich der.
Der Öffentlichkeit und auf der Bedrohung die im solchen Aufforderung zur Gewalt einhergeht.
Preiszugeben und das ist z.b. auch relevant für Leute die sagen wir mal vielleicht sich über 10 Jahre,
entwickeln ja und sagen ach okay krass hier anfangs habe ich nur ein bisschen geblockt inzwischen habe ich da eine ausreichende Leserschaft und
dazu gehört eben jetzt auch dass ich mich neuerdings irgendwie gegen die AFD äußern und in Wirklichkeit wissen wissen die Leute über die ich mich da äußer,
seit soundsoviel Jahren,
da wo ich wohne ich habe die hier auch nicht die den Plan umzuziehen und selbst wenn ich umziehe muss ich an meine neue Adresse auch ins Internet schreiben das ist denke ich schon Problem für für die Meinungsfreiheit noch für die,
für den Schutz dieser Personen und die Idee zu sagen mehr okay dann schafft doch bitte wenigstens eine.
Möglichkeit das nett dass man also eine zustellungsbevollmächtigte,
Adresse angibt also z.b. wenn da steht die Adresse muss ladungsfähig sein kannst halt kein Postfach angeben da werde ich werde schöne,
wenn es schöne Option gibt sich insofern finde ich diesen Antrag eigentlich sehr schön wird allerdings nicht mit diskutiert werden weil die FDP sich eben hier,
auf IT Sicherheit als Kernthema dieses Antrages festgelegt hat und deswegen so was so ein,
sag mal beides ist in der Bürgerrechts und sonstige Teile betreffenden Antrag dann nicht mit drin haben wollte.
Kann ich die Argumentation kann ich auch wiederum nachvollziehen dass der hätte da jetzt ein bisschen heraus gestanden andererseits ist das der Antrag der am nächsten dran ist.
An dieser Auslöser doxing ne,
impressumspflichten schlichtweg können alle Bundestagsabgeordneten was weiß ich die Geschäftsstelle der Partei angeben als Treuhänder für für für Anfragen oder als zustellungsbevollmächtigte wäre unter Umständen,
ein großer Teil der Bundestagsabgeordneten gar nicht in diesem in diesem gewesen.
Was heißt denn genau zustellungsbevollmächtigt was hast du denn da für ein Verständnis davon also kann ich dann nur.
Ich stelle mir vor so eine Art boxine.
Ja gut ich meiner kann dann gib mal 20 Adressen von irgendwelchen Feinden an hoffe.
Nein nein nein nein nein nein nein nein nein also,
es gibt noch es ist natürlich zu klären wer das ist das könnt ja z.b. auch eine bundesinstitutionen sein wo du sagst hier übrigens meine ladungsfähige Anschrift ist soundso falls sich da jemand falls da jemand.
Einen berechtigten Anspruch vorlegt das zu erfahren oder einen berechtigten Anspruch vorlegt.
Der mir zugestellt werden muss dann kann das hier bitte passieren ist doch auch ein Klassiker sind doch was du auch hasse diese diese Anzeigen die gegen Leute passieren dass sie jetzt irgendwie baltin in Situationen von Demonstration und Gegendemonstration.
Wird daneben Anzeige erstattet gegen jemanden
und dann haben das wäre natürlich die Anwälte bemüht und die Anwälte können Akteneinsicht verlangen und so bekommst du dann eben an die Adresse des Gegendemonstranten und dann kannst du den schön in deine.
In deiner Anti-Antifa liste einführen ne also dieser dieser dieser ich fand das eben,
sehr interessant das große Thema an diesem boxing Angriff Eier im Prinzip nur oder die die Veröffentlichung von,
die Veröffentlichung von nur der Wohnadresse und wir haben relativ viel Debatte darüber gehabt gleichzeitig verlangen wir im Prinzip von jeder Privatperson diziyo wo es hat dass sie,
diese eben auch öffentlich zugänglich und das ist natürlich wahrscheinlich.
Auch eine sehr gute Quelle für derartige Datensammlung das weiß ich sogar dass es so ist ich meinte er soll denn noch irgendwie groß suchen für seinen doxing wenn die Leute ihre Adresse irgendwo offen hinschreiben.
Also ich kriege gerade noch mal ein bisschen rum was irgendwie,
erlaubt ist oder nicht aber dafür bin ich richtig zu wenig bewandert um das hier wirklich mal genau noch mal nachzuschlagen,
auf jeden Fall wäre das wünschenswert dass ich hier was verbessert weil es gibt einfach auch keine Notwendigkeit also es ist einfach es ist immer so dieser Deutschland ist aber die Gesetzgebung oft immer beseelt und natürlich auch so die politische Debatte von diesem Fernseher Vorstellung.
Und was ist denn wenn was passiert.
Es wird zurzeit immer angenommen dass in der Zukunft mal alles komplett schief gehen kann ohne dass man zu dem Zeitpunkt wo man sich die Gesetze erlassen hat nennenswert schon.
Schlimme Dinge passiert sind die jetzt wirklich eine solche Maßnahme erforderlich machen na und diese Angst Haltung.
German Angst für daneben einfach auch zu Problemen die sonst gar nicht erst da gewesen wären.
Kommen wir zu den Kurzmeldungen Liebert.
Da muss ich noch mal was z.b.
Ich sagte mal morgen so einfach so ich ließ den Titel vor und ich gebe dir 15 Sekunden.
Nee ich brauche 25.
Achso ja ok wieder Sonderregelung und sondern bei dir muss wieder alles anders laufen.
Der hat der Bundesverband der Bäckerei Industrie Bitkom lässt verlauten sechs von zehn und Internetnutzern haben Angst vor Cyber kriegen.
Da ist sie wieder die Angst.
Und die Mehrheit der Nutzer befürwortet deswegen Hack und Back da freut sich natürlich das Bäckerei Handwerk.
Das ist für mich so ein klassisches klassisches Beispiel für wie du die Frage stellst.
Definierst du natürlich auch die Antwort nein du gehst dann irgendwie in den eine Forsa-Umfrage oder so die Frage rein finden Sie uns ziehen Sie dass wir uns im Cyberkrieg wären sollten können dann sagen irgendwie sechzig Prozent der Leute ja,
weniger Prozent der Leute nein ich finde das sehr diese diese wir haben mal eine Umfrage gemacht dass es immer natürlich mit sehr sehr sehr viel Vorsicht zu genießen und
aber es ist natürlich gleichzeitig ein einem.
Ein guter Messwert wende mich in einer Umfrage des im Auftrag des Bäckerei Branchenverbands BITKOM fünf 50 % der Befragten befürworten das Deutschland selbst aktiv mit Cyberattacken zurückschlagen soll.
Nun schlecht dass die Diskussion in diese Richtung geht.
Haben wir auf jeden Fall noch eine bisschen Aufklärung,
vor uns um diese dass hier nicht nur diese einzelne Frage sondern die gesamte Breite der Diskussion einmal wieder zu spielen dass sie nicht um eine defensive ausrichten.
Dann Tesla eine äußerst peinliche Korrektur nach,
irgendwie zwei Jahren zur der Effizienz und Effektivität Ihres Autopiloten irgendwie Autos dir heiß ich dachte der ist Autopilot aber wie auch immer.
Denn Tesla hat damals gesagt wir haben.
Mit die TestAS mit dem Spurassistenten haben 40% weniger Airbagauslösung an einen auch ein sehr interessanter Kennwert ja mehr damals das war dass das erste Todesopfer glaube ich,
in einem Autounfall zu beklagen war in dem das Auto automatisch gesteuert wurde.
Dann sind eben gesagt na ja der Durchschnittsmensch fährt so und so viel Kilometer ohne Unfall unser Autopilot vor so und so viel Kilometer mehr sondern immer soeben Operationalisierungen von Sicherheit und hier sagen sie eben die Operationalisierung ist,
Airbag Auslösungen an sie gesagt das sind 40% weniger das hat der Elon Musk himself Anfang 2017.
Zitiert aus einem Untersuchungsbericht der US Straßenverkehrs Sicherheitsbehörde nacsa,
leider hat die Behörde sich da aber vertan denn die sind nicht um 40% niedriger als 100 um 59% höher.
So dass Sie hiermit korrigiert.
Kann ja mal passieren.
Ja wichtig ist das bei Prozentwerten dass ich das immer auf 100 addiert scheiße und ja also doch nicht.
Doch lieber noch mal extra Airbag mitbestellen Nähe den Autopiloten ab,
dann gibt's ein neues Lied diesmal 620 Millionen Accounts nicht öffentlich sondern zum Verkauf ich glaube das war eben sowas die 20 000 US-Dollar die man dafür bezahlen sollte,
betroffen sind in der Tat hauptsächlich Services die ich alle nicht kenne also kenne ich nicht einen einzigen von doch mal Visp erkenne ich
der war der der war aber öffentlich bekannt dass es den gab da waren sind die Daten nur nie wieder aufgetaucht jetzt kann man sich dir also kaufen also wenn ihr euer Passwort von meinem Fitness Perl zurück haben wollt dann könnt ihr das da,
für 20011 $ bekommen und kriegt noch.
620 619 Millionen 999999 Accounts mit dazu.
Da kann man das auch mit Bitcoin bezahlen.
Kartoffelpizza mit zahlen wenn das dann.
Wahrscheinlich sogar nur oder mit monero oder was auch immer hier die Crypto kabelzieh der Wahl ist wichtig ist übrigens bei deinem Bild, dass du die gut sicher.
Wirklich.
Ja wir hatten nämlich jetzt einen einen schönen Fall von digitales digitales Erbe.
Ich habe da noch ganz ganz viel bei quadrigacx noch gespeichert.
Ja das ist gut das hätte ich auch schon längere Zeit gespeichert bleiben die Kunst bei Quadriga sind jetzt auf jeden Fall sicher weil der einzige Mensch der das Passwort hatte um den off,
den offline storage wallet aufzumachen.
In dem 137 Millionen US-Dollar in Crypto currencies gespeichert sind ist leider überraschend gestorben.
30 Jahre alt plötzlicher Tod tragischer Fall insbesondere eben weil er der einzige war der dieses Passwort kannte für das sogenannte cold Wallet also den.
Ihr das Wallet was quasi ohne Zugang zum Internet gehalten wird einfach um den um die anderes Oberfläche zu verringern keine schlechte Idee wenn man 137 Millionen US-Dollar aufbewahrt,
die 100.000 unglücklichen Kunden gehören da sollte man höhere Sicherheitsmaßnahmen ergreifen natürlich ungünstig wenn die Sicherheitsmaßnahme beinhaltet das nur eine Person.
Das Passwort kennt.
Tja Scheiße muss ich wieder sparen.
Ja da gibt's noch ein also Sicherheit ist natürlich problematisch ne also ich dich mein ich finde das sehr gut das also,
dass sie die Sicherheit hat sie sogar so gut ist dass du dein Geheimnis mit ins Grab nehmen kannst,
aber wenn ihr also Daten verschlüsselt und besonders kryptografisch sicher dann.
Solltet ihr eben auch überlegen dass diese Sicherheitsmaßnahme euch unter Umständen,
überlebt das kann von Vorteil sein das kann von Nachteil sein gerade wenn man sich jetzt irgendwie Vorbereitungen lange mal kontozugriffe für,
den irgendwann früher oder später unvermeidlichen Fall eines Erbes dann kann man sich natürlich darüber Gedanken machen ob man sich hier nicht verschiedener,
kryptographischer Verfahren bedient um sicherzustellen das was was ich.
Die wichtigsten Zugänge dem Nachwuchs übergeben werden aber die über die Jahre angehäufte Pornosammlung z.b. nicht ne oder dass man sagt erst mit 18 oder so ne das könnte man also durchaus soll hilft es sich auch darüber,
Gedanken ja Daten die auch nicht hätten anfangen sollen sind die,
im Rahmen der Verfassungsbeschwerde im im Rahmen dieser Zensus Vorbereitung für den Testlauf an gesammelten Daten da wurde ja der Eilantrag der Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte,
abgelehnt deswegen hat sie nun eine Verfassungsbeschwerde gegen die Massen,
hafte Übermittlung von Meldedaten im Rahmen dieses Testlauf ist angestrengt eine wünschen wir natürlich unseren Freunden bei der GFF Ding,
großen Erfolg mit dieser Verfassungsbeschwerde.
Ja und dann wurde der BMW neu eröffnet in Berlin bist ja umgezogen
Teil des dddd sind umgezogen der die Skandal Behörde sitzt immer noch in Pullach aber dieser dieser schöne Neubau in Berlin wurde jetzt irgendwie Eingeweihter Gasthaus Reifentest,
confesta kann man hätte jetzt erwartet dass bei diesem Festakt einfach mal so ein paar Leute mit Wasserhähnen.
Vorbeikommen und noch von den ein oder anderen Wasserhahn Spenden versteht den Witz.
Ich schon ja die Wunder mal geklaut.
Haben alle Wasserhähne geklaut
Stadt die Bude unter Wasser weil da tagelang Wasser gelaufen ist ne und außerdem ist das Gebäude ja mit wem Scannern geschützt die Starbuck und Julian ja beim,
35 C3 öffentlich präsentiert haben wie man die umgehen kann der fast da wäre sie jetzt auf jeden Fall ein Quell der Freude in Berlin.
Und uns wurde von den FDGO Ultras die,
na vielleicht dort waren oder auch nicht eine kleine Beschreibung des Festaktes.
Zugesandt die wir gerne zum Besten geben möchten.
Ach ja du da angebaut.
Möchtest du die möchtest du diese Zusammenfassung des Festaktes verlesen oder soll ich das machen.
Okay mach das jetzt mal Note wirkt nicht sehr begeistert neben Sense zu sitzen Karl sagt nichts Besonderes nutzt wird wie ein Genick,
merke dir mit historisch anekdotisch Wolf Biermann der um die Ecke produziert hat neue Erfindung gehen die erfolgreich install bielefeld,
BRD unverzichtbar Mutti dankbar fake-news accessing Teil Hybride Kriegsführung,
sende wird geradezu gerührt noch guckt skeptisch größter Witz der Serverraum wirken noch beeindruckender als das Atrium,
Ernst yes it is in Syrien auch BRD essentiell.
Zweites Thema Cyber Hybride Kriegsführung ein Krieg der über das weltweite Netz ausgetragen wird,
wenn ich sage mehr Personal ist gut dann auch für die anderen Behörden wegen de hat keine Rohstoffe,
Wirtschaft für de wichtig Multilateralismus die Lösung Kooperation mit anderen Diensten unabdingbar mit Frankreich European intelligence network aber auch England und USA wegen Terrorismus lebensnotwendig,
bei Nachrichtendiensten sind wir in de zurecht hochsensibel siehe Stasi beim BND hingegen weiß ich dass er auf dem
Boden des Grundgesetzes steht in ein enges Netz von Aufsicht und parlamentarischer Kontrolle eingebettet ist und seinen gesetzlichen Auftrag mit Augenmaß erfüllt.
Sieht ja nicht jeder so Sensburg schmunzelt Notz Ernst Schlusssatz sie tun etwas dafür dass Millionen von Deutschen sicher leben können und dafür vielen Dank.
Alle stehen auf Holz blas Quintett spielt Nationalhymne viele singen mit Notes auch Smartphones werden gezückt.
War das ist doch wirklich ergreifend oder.
Ja ich will fühl mich so als wäre ich gerade da gewesen.
Also da dann da tatsächlich nichts Neues dann wir noch ein oh ja dass das ist ein interessantes Thema wären jobangebote.
Achso.
Aber wir haben einen Jobangebot zu verbreiten.
Und zwar sucht reporter-ohne-grenzen eine neue Referentin für Internetfreiheit in Berlin für eine volle unbefristete.
Stelle wie muss man sich die Job vorstellen du blickst Kontakte in die Journalismus Netzpolitik,
Menschenrechts Zähne in Deutschland und weltweit planst und identifizierst Mittel und langfristige Themen in den Feldern Internetfreiheit und Journalismus du analysierst politische Entwicklungen beim Thema Internetfreiheit und formulierst,
Reporter ohne Grenzen spezifische Positionen für Interviews pressemitteilungen Kampagnen advocacy Arbeit,
sowie Briefings für Vorstand und Geschäftsführung du beantwortest Fragen und gibt Interviews zu aktuellen Themen nimmt an Veranstaltung teil kommunizierst mit dem internationalen Sekretariat von Reporter ohne Grenzen,
in Paris ja da gibt's also eine unbefristete Stelle im,
ja andjeo aktivistischen contact für eine wichtige Sache nämlich reporter-ohne-grenzen und die,
die Stihl Stellenausschreibung ist bei uns in den shoutouts verlinkt,
es gibt auch noch Praktikum im Presserat und ein Praktikum im Referat Öffentlichkeitsarbeit Bewerbung ausschließlich per E-Mail in einem! PDF-Dokument maximal 3 MB.
Und da könnt ihr euch also Rahmen hinwenden.
Maximal 3 MB also keine hohe Auflösung.
Aber das bei dem Praktiker ich muss gerade gucken das war bei den Praktika ohohohohoh bei dem bei dem Praktiker maximal 3 MB bei der bei der ReferentInnen Stelle maximal anderthalb MB.
Disney store.
Keine Ahnung warum.
Na die Stelle ist nicht so hoch aufgelöst.
Ja aber dann nur da nur anderthalb MB und bis Sonntag 3. März das ist also in zweieinhalb Wochen müsst ihr euch dann beworben.
Könnt ihr euch noch mal anschauen ob das nicht vielleicht eine eine Stelle ist in der ihr euch engagieren Wort.
Ja ich denke das bringt uns jetzt zu den Terminen.
Aux
Am Freitag jetzt Freitag den 15. März 2019 findet in der Seaways zu Berlin die Defensive Kronstadt im Seminarraum,
da soll es darum gehen,
als Alternative zu einer parallel stattfinden Konferenz mit eher zweifelhaftem ethischen Hintergrund die Gelegenheit zu nutzen und aktiv über Defensive ID Sicherheit Gedanken zu machen.
Unsere ethischen Werte gemeinsam zu re kalibrieren.
Und wenn ihr euch ausreichend Reh kalibriert habt dann könnt ihr schon am Wochenende direkte darauf nehme ich den 16 und 17 März vielleicht nach
Chemnitz begeben denn dort finden statt die Chemnitzer Linux Tage das ist ja eine extrem althergebrachte Veranstaltung ich weiß gar nicht wie lange die jetzt schon
läuft auf jeden Fall gibt's auch diesmal wieder unter dem Motto natürlich intelligent,
abwechslungsreiches Vortrag zum Workshop Programm rund um Linux OpenSource und andere Themen das ganze,
im Hörsaal und Seminargebäude der TU Chemnitz.
Hitlers sehr schön die Chemnitzer Linux Tage.
Wird das gesagt ich habe nix das wär doch mal was.
Die kenne ich Saline tahoe und dann machen wir darauf aufmerksam.
Normalerweise können wir einen Termin nur einmal an aber diesen hatten wir auf bitte so früh angekündigt am 28 Februar in Bamberg in der neue collibri Buchhandlung.
Cyberwar die Gefahr aus dem Netz mit frank 28er Februar 1930 in Bamberg ich hoffe dass das jetzt inzwischen die Nachricht ist bis nach Bamberg geschafft hat wir wünschen euch noch viel Spaß.
Damit sind wir am Ende der Sendung.
AOK gut ist doch schön ja demnächst dann vielleicht bei mir wieder auch mit der gewunden Klangqualität da bin ich jetzt hier gerade noch im Übergang.
Ja das ist so erbärmlich.
Nüsse
bisschen erbärmlich aber so ist das nun mal mit mit noch nicht vollständig eingerichteten Studio Situation naja aber ich bin ja jetzt hier so ein bisschen den Süden übergesiedelt
und genieße auf jeden Fall schon mal das angenehmere Klima hat er so alles seine Vorteile.
Sehr schön da freuen wir uns so geht das noch etwas zu sagen Lena.
Tschüss, sagen ne bis dann ciao.